[Musique]
Alexandre Jardin bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle sinkervview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement euh je m'appelle
Alexandre Jardin je
beaucoup de gens croient que je suis
écrivain parce que j'ai j'ai beaucoup
écrit j'écris beaucoup euh je suis aussi
je vais
devenir si la vie me le permet je vais
redevenir mur en scène je l'ai été à un
moment j'ai des des très gros projets
qui sont en cours de montage
euh donc je j'ai l'air d'un artiste et
et et et puis à côté de ça je me suis
toujours occupé de de mon pays
en essayant de construire moi-même des
solutions quand il y en avait pas
et donc j'ai monté beaucoup de
mouvements citoyens beaucoup
d'associations dont une que les gens
connaissent peut-être très populaire qui
s'appelle lire et
faerlire pour essayer de transmettre le
plaisir de la
lecture aux enfants de manière à
à les remplir de mots et et et on
s'occupe de 750000 enfants avec presque
20000 bénévoles on a décidé de faire une
interview avec vous il y a 2 mois au au
au départ de de la révolte contre les
afeux qu'est-ce que les AFE qu'est-ce
quels sont les problèmes ça expose
combien de personnes comment ça peut ça
pu arriver sur la table est-ce qu'il y a
une déconnexion des politiques par
rapport à la réalité de terrain on va
parler tout plein de choses ce soir
ensemble je vous laisse je te laisse
commencer
euh au départ
je
découvre je fais partie des gens qui
étaient pas vraiment au
courant parce que je travaillais
beaucoup en naie au courant de quoi au
courant de l'existence de cette loi de
ces lois successives qui ont créé les
AFE les zones de faible émission oui et
que qu' aujourd'hui le peuple appelle
les zones de fortte exclusion
euh d'ailleurs j'ai failli dire ça et
non pas le nom officiel tellement c'est
devenu courant euh j'avais pas suivi
exactement plutôt je m'étais pas
vraiment rendu compte un de l'impact de
l'énormité du
truc et je m'en rends compte le le 31
décembre
dernier très peu de temps dans un
village de l'ude dans une boulangerie où
il y a un type très énervé très remonté
parce que il peut pas récupérer ses
enfants le à partir du lendemain c'est
ce qu'il m'explique il explique aux gens
parce qu'il a pas pas la bonne voiture
il a divorcé et ses enfants sont avec la
mère dans une ZFE dans une ville fermée
pour toute une catégorie de voiture et
il m'explique il a pas la bonne et dans
ce village c'est absolument évident que
personne n'a les moyens de changer de
voiture on est on est dans un
département rural il y a de années de
crise extrêmement dure
viticol on partait pas déjà de très haut
donc c'est évident qu' on peut pas et
lui peut pas changer de voiture et il se
demande comment il va faire à ce moment
un autre qui arrive qui sort de la
boulanger qui lui dit oui mais je crois
que ça marche quand même le weekend il
dit mais non moi j'ai j'ai
un je parle de tous ces détails parce
que ce sont ces détails qui n'ont pas
été vus par les gens qui sont les
auteurs
de de ces lois successive il dit mais
moi j'ai divorcé je dois récupérer les
enfants à 16h30 le vendredi et je
m'entends pas très bien avec mon ex et
elle elle est pas commode et il faut que
j'y aille et arrive un autre qui dit
mais moi je connais un chemin on peut
rentrer en douce sans se faire goer par
les flics il y a pas d'appareil photo il
y a pas de radar de caméras ouais et il
commence à lui montrer sur son téléphone
c'est-à-dire que tout à coup il y a un
j'ai en face de moi un type qui est
plutôt un gentil papa qui veut s'occuper
de ses gamins et je me retrouve dans
dans un film français en noir et blanc
des années 40 avec une ligne de
démarcation et et un gars qui est un
suspect aux yeux de la loi mais comme
ça ils prennent le maquille ensemble par
un chemin ouais donc tout à coup fait
une situation
invraisemblable ma première réaction
j'ai du mal à croire que c'est
complètement vrai je me dis il non pas
du ça me paraît bizarre ça me paraît
tellement extravagant je rentre je me
renseigne et je je comprends que c'est
vrai donc Z fe ça met combien de
véhicules au Robus ça ça déclasse
combien de personnes c'est partir du 1er
janvier 12 millions de véhicule
800000 motos janvier de cette année ouis
c'est opérationnel pendant qu'on parle
après je vais expliquer pourquoi les
pouvoirs publics ont la trouille
d'appliquer leur propre loi et mais en
même temps quand même le processus est
lancé parlons chiffre donc 12 millions
de
véhicules ça veut dire à peu près entre
22 et 26 millions de gens parce que
comme les garçons ont tendance à coucher
avec les filles ça fait des couples il
font des
petits en fait ça fait du monde ça fait
un tiers de la
nation qui se retrouve alors au début je
crois queil sont interdit
d'accè qui peuvent pas rentrer dans les
grosses villes je vois qu'il y en a 42
mais en même temps sont il y en a qui
ont fait des
exceptions en
gros je m'aperçois que c'est bien pire
parce que dans les les AFE intègrent les
rocades et les
autoroutes
donc les
gu je vais expliquer pourquoi j'emploie
ce mot les guux sont assignés à
résidence s'ils peuvent pas changer de
bagnole le truc ils peuvent aller juste
dans le village d'à côté mais ils
peuvent pas prendre l'autoroute pas
prendre une nationale qui passe trop
près du d'une grande ville et
et je vais dire même si les radars sont
pas encore branchés ils n'ont pas un
niveau de vie qui leur permet
d'encaisser une
prune donc en vrai ils sont déjà
enfermés parce que si il y a un un
contrôle de la gendarmerie ça va les
taper dans des niveaux qu' ne peuvent
pas ils nont pas non seulement ils ont
pas l'argent pour changer la voiture
mais ils font partie de ces 25 % de
Français qui au mois de janvier dernier
étaient dans le rouge à à partir du 15
du
mois donc ils peuvent pas prendre une
prune le 68 € de la prune il est
inconcevable on est trop réraque et ça
va avoir des conséquences sur ce qu'ils
vont bouffer sur donc donc en fait ils
sont déjà coincés et parce qu'il y a
cette zone d'incertitude est-ce qu'
est-ce que la police va nous choper
est-ce que donc on a cadriller tout le
pays de ZFE il y en a 42
elles sont pas toutes encore déjà
activées mais la loi dit que c'est comme
ça
euh avec des variations je reviendra
dessus ça me paraît tellement dément que
je je fais je fais un tweet et je
termine de manière très provoque en
disant mais on s'en fout c'est des
gueux je trouve un mot je me suis dit le
mot du mépris qu c'est le le vieux mot
français qui voulait dire te regarde en
haut le mot du
méprix je suis tellement effaré que je
cherche un mot qui va taper et puis jour
de l'an fiesta et je me souviens plus si
c'est exactement le lendemain ou sur
lendemain je rallume mon téléphone et je
vois qu'il y a
516000 ça va ensuite ça va continuer
personnes qui sont venu le voir qui nont
le d'habitude il y a 2000 12000
20000 mais pas un demimillion de gens
donc je comprends que j'ai tapé dans un
truc
euh que j'ai pas rêvé que je suis pas
dans un mauvais film en fait le réel
répond tout de suite tout de suite alors
je continue à chercher et puis je
découvre que
l'humiliation s mêlé de la partie parce
que non seulement on les humilie en en
en les parquant mais en plus dans les
ZFE on a imaginé un truc extraordinaire
qui sont euh oui euh j'ai oublié un truc
important quand je rallume mon téléphone
je découvre que le ils on on fait un
hashtag que le hashtag
gu
m'échappe les gens se reconnaissent
là-dedans et dans les semaines qui vont
suivre la presse va l'utiliser la presse
locale va l'utiliser sur des tas
d'autres sujets les gens vont parler de
gu alors qu'on en parlait pas et au fond
ce mot qui va synthétiser à la fois de
l'ironie sur soi-même parce que c'est un
peu une vanne mais c'est une mauvaise
vane
douloureuse ça va résumer le mépris
français le mépris des politiciens
ouis plus que les politiciens parce que
plus je fouille plus je me rends compte
que il y a vraiment deux sortes de
mépris qui qui qui n'ont rien àir il y a
celui de je te méprise ouvertement et
celui qui consiste à ne même pas te
voir or ces gens c'est un/ers de la
nation n'ont pas été vu et parce que par
les réseaux commence à me remonter les
études d'impact des des lois successives
notamment cell de 2021 la loi résilience
enfin déjà le nom résilience les les or
l'étude d'impact est un document de 645
pages je fouille dedans avec un ami qui
était lui-même un ancien directeur de
cabinet plus habitué que moi à fouiller
là-dedans et il m'aide et on trouve le
passage qui est consacré aux guux aux
gens ça fait moins d'une page moins
d'une page il y a un truc qui va
concerner un tiers de la nation l'étude
d'impact c'est moins d'une page et c'est
passé comme ça
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est passé dans
toutes les commissions au Sénat il non
et dans la page ils n'ont pas compté
les ils ont pas compté le nombre de
voitures et le nombre d'êtres humains il
se lance dans la plus grande opération
de tri humain de notre histoire
depuis anné
40 oui mais c'est ça parce que quand on
trie les voitures on trie les humains
c'est ça le truc et donc on commence à
remettre en question on va revenir
là-dessus
mais on casse le pacte républicain parce
que tout à coup il y a une rupture
d'égalité qui est devient
institutionnalisée légalisé euh avec les
moyens de la police enfin un truc de fou
qu
et et donc je fouille de truc je je me
dis ils ont pas été vus euh euh
on les a pas estimé il y a personne dans
les cabinets il y a personne au
Parlement qui a dit mais c'est de la
fouise cette étude d'impact pire que
tout le Grand
Paris fait pas une étude d'impact mais
une consultation et remet un rapport au
mois de novembre
2024 ce rapport dit que
% 94 % sont
contre le rapport on le fout de côté et
au fond ce qui est très extraordinaire
sincèrement tu es tu as une fonction tu
es à la tête du Grand
Paris on t'apporte ça tu dis peut-être
qu'on va il va peut-être un petit souci
surtout après les gilets jaunes oui
surtout après les G mais c'est qu'on a
tellement pas rien appris des les jaunes
que même quand il y a un rapport qui
balance un chiffre comme ça alors par
les réseaux toujours parce évidment
c'est une centrale de
renseignement remonte également l'étude
faite par le Sénat auprès de 50000
français quelle année elle est remise au
mois de juillet
dernier juillet
2 cette étude dit que 87 % ou je sais
plus si 87 ou 86
enfin sont contre et ils vont le
voter ils vont le voter parce que on est
dans dans la
bulle dans un milieu à Paris un milieu
politique où il y a des choses qu'on
ninterroge plus il y a un espace mental
qui n'est plus
interrogé et on doit purifier l'air
c'est comme
ça quoi qu'il en coûte quoi qu'il en
coûte et interroger ça se poser la
question même est-ce qu'on n pas en
train de délirer alors que les la
population est en train de dire des
choses dans des proportions monstrueuses
non ça appartient à la zone qu'on ne
peut plus interroger et en fait quand un
milieu commence à produire de la pensée
qui n'est plus interrogé il peut faire
n'importe quoi
et donc j'ai discuté après avec des
sénateurs parce que aujourd'hui après je
vais dire ce qui est en
train je mais qu'est-ce qui t'a
pris il me dit mais je pense
à la rég de Montan qui me dit mais on
[Musique]
était tout le monde pensait qu'on
faisait
bien c'est ça le mépris
c'est du mépris ou c'est du fait qu'ils
sont plus du tout connectés avec les
territoires c'est la forme supérieure du
mépris ce qu'on appelle la déconnexion
c'est ça consiste à considérer que
l'autre s'en fout et quand je demande au
mère de mon village un soir on March
dans la rue je dis mais commentexlique
un truc pareil soit possible il dit très
simplement il réfléchit même pas
mais pour on nexiste pas
mais toi tu le vois à l'occasion de la
ZFE mais moi je le vis tout le temps
tous les
jours sur tous les
sujets on n'existe pas
donc je comprends petit à petit que la
crise des ZFE va être la faute de car de
trop par le
nombre parce que là c'est plus un sujet
technique mais c'est un sujet de
République puisqu une rupture d'égalité
de discrimination territoriale et
sociale parce qu'en fait c'est des zones
entières qui qui vont être
exclus donc on touche à la racine même
au fondement même de la République et
c'est à ce moment-là quand je comprends
vraiment ça que je me dis que je vais
jamais
lâcher que je vais structurer ça et que
je vais accompagner mon pays parce que
on est en train de sortir de de de de la
trajectoire
républicaine est en train d'entrer dans
une forme de de démocratie libérale on n
pas besoin de
Trump on y va tout seul
et ça se tout ça est fait par des
gens
gentils très cool c'estàd que la
domination elle est présentée de manière
cool c'est pour l'air
pur alors après je vais revenir sur les
soucis écologiques parce que bien sûr
qu'on a des soucis écologiques mais est-
estce qu'on est prêt à dynamiter les
fondements mêmes de notre lien social et
à démarrer un processus de ségrégation
sociale c'est qu'on est en train de
toucher à des choses mais d'une gravité
sans
nom je me pose même des questions par
rapport au Conseil
constitutionnel comment ils ont pu
valider un truc pareil et là on voit que
le à partir du moment où on a introduit
la planète le principe de
précaution dans la
Constitution il y a des conflits qui
font que ça on ne garantit plus les
libertés publiques fondamentales donc ça
passe donc c'est
admis l'air pur qui est
contre et bien moi je suis absolument
contre comme l'écrasante majorité des
Français qui sont en train de se
reconnaître jour après jour derrière le
hashtag gu je suis absolument contre une
écologie violente non républicaine
de ségrégation et je veux comme tout le
monde de l'air plus purure on est normau
personne envie de
respir mais on veut une écologie non
violente une écologie qui n'est pas une
écologie de l'hyper contrôle social
parce qu'en réalité derrière tout ça ça
nous fait basculer dans de l'hyper
contrôle social alors après je va dire
comment ils ont reculé pour essayer de
faire avaler
le alors plus ils ont
reculé plus le mépris c'est ils l'ont
fait de manière méprisante notamment la
ville de
Paris on voit une vidéo avec le
responsable de l'écologie la ville de
Paris qui dit oui mais en gros on est
humain donc on va faire des pass
gu il appelle pas comme ça mais
aujourd'hui sur les raisons on appelle
ça des pass petit
rouleur c'est pire
tu as le droit par exemple à Paris 24
fois par an mais il faut pas être trop
spontané faut s'y prendre à l'avance tu
vas sur le site de la
Commune de Paris et tu sollicites un peu
de
mensuétude pour avoir le droit en tant
que gue qui peut pas se payer un
changement de voiture de t'infiltrer
chez les
riches de telle heure à telle heure
parce que c'est très encadré il y a des
hires et là le gu a le droit de se fau
chez le riche pour voir coucou et
pendant ce temps il voit que celui qui a
les moyens rentre avec une testla rentre
avec la
voiture convient mais comme le est
intelligent et qui connait mieux les
bagnoles que les politiques il sait que
il a une voiture qui poll très souvent
beaucoup moins que celle qui est
autorisé puisqueen fait on n pas retenu
un critère de pollution mais un critère
d'année c'est le truc de débile donc il
y a des voitures qui sont virées alors
qu'elles roulent au GPL alors que les
gens étaient hyper
écolos
donc premier recul hop il s imagine de
manière bureaucratique de manière
cauchemardesque parce que toutes les ZFE
vont s'y mettre il y a il y a des
dérogations à peau il y a des
passgux ils ont même fait mieux ils ont
ils sont dit on va faire on va aménager
parce qu'on est humain vous allez
pouvoir venir on va faire des parkings
avec des bus et donc ceux qui vont dans
les parcs sont en train de comprendre
que c'est des parcs à
guux parce que le riche passe sous leur
nez et on est quand même un peuple
républicain donc tout à coup les gens il
sont normaux ils se disent mais attends
moi je et puis c'est complètement une
vue d'esprit parce que tout ça est fait
pour quelqu'un de 32 ans quand tu es
vieux tu fais comment
accessoirement ces parkings sont en
train de devenir des zones de
délinquence donc le soir tu as pas
forcément envie quand tu es une femme
seule accessoirement enfin c'est
beaucoup plus complexe donc c'est le
réel des gens
euh donc premier aménagement les pass gu
ensuite ils vont comme il voit que leurs
artisans leurs machins leurs trucs en
fait personne ne peut ça bloque
entièrement un certain nombre
d'activités donc ils vont augmenter le
nombre de passes
le nombre de de de de
dérogations ça veut dire qu'on accepte
là pendant qu'on est en train de parler
on est rentré dans l'aire de la mise
sous tutelle administrative des
déplacements des
guux que les riches sont
libres alors il y a plein de communes
qui se sont révolté il y a eu un type
extraordinaire qui sappelle Laurent jaou
qui est le maire de saintbray qui est
une des 31 communes de l'agglomération
de de Montpellier qui lui s'aperçoit que
dans sa petite commune il a 2000 cartes
grises et sur les 2000 il y en a 900 qui
sont
virés en clair s'il va à la boulangerie
et qu'il fait pas quelque chose pour les
900 oui
voilà donc il va prendre prendre la tête
d'une révolte il va prendre son
téléphone au début ils sont 4 sur les 31
il en convain 23 ou 24 il prend la
majorité et il repousse jusqu'à 2027
contre la vie du ma écolo fou de rage
parce que lui il voulait exclure le gu
et et si possible verbaliser le plus
vite possible donc il il réussit à
repousser ça ce Laurent Jaoul va devenir
une star dans les médias locaux dans le
Midi Libre ça va finir par faire la une
du Midi Libre et puis doucement les
médias nationaux vont inviter l'or Jaoul
il va devenir un être symbolique et ce
qui fait que il y a plein de Laurent
Jaoul en ce moment qui sont en train de
discuter pour essayer d'inverser parce
qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont les 900
cartes grises sur les
2000 alors Pays-Basque c'est en train de
bouger euh en fait c'est c'est en train
de se
fissurer c'est est-ce que tu as est-ce
que tu as évalué le coût oui voilà
combien alors le le coût c'est peut-être
le grand sujet social parce qu'en fait
il y a il y a plein de télés qui m'ont
demandé de venir m'opposer à des
écologistes je veux pas m'opposer à des
écologistes c'est pas un sujet
d'écologie c'est un sujet de République
c'est un sujet social et et le volet
social c'est que quasiment du jour au
lendemain la valeur de ces 12 millions
de véhicules a disparu donc on a
désintégré à peu près 65 milliards donc
ces 12 millions ça représente comment
comment tu as fait pour calculer alors
bah j'ai recoupé les différents trucs
là-dedans il y a il y a c'est un peu
plus que 12 millions parce que il y a à
peu près 11 millions 4 véhicules et puis
800000 motos de
rou il y a pas que des motos il y a bon
mais il y a eu donc c'est un peu plus
que que 12 millions depuis le 1er
janvier
et en gros la perte par foyer elle est
entre 2 SPIC et demi et
5 pour des foyers qui avaient mis tout
leur argent pratiquement dans une
voiture péculle de sécurité des classes
popul français qui vient de
flamber sans qu'on en parle sans que ça
a été calculé et les gens qui vont
m'aider à calculer tout ça c'est les
cabinets de président de Région parce
que après je vais dire toutes les
réactions mais en gros il y a une perte
sèche d'argent qui est l'équivalent d'un
impôt qui qu'on aurait prélevé sur les
classes populaires françaises entre 2 et
demi et 5 SMIC c'est un truc de malade
donc à chaque fois que le gouvernement
va
proposer de repousser un report ou de
suspendre c'est de pas annuler ça veut
dire qu'il s'en fout que les pauvres
payent un impôt de 2 et demi à 5
SP puisque leur bagnole n'est plus
vendable c'est que quand ils vont au
garage Renault du coin pour essayer
autrefois qu'est-ce qu'on faisait je dis
autrefois les on allait au garage et il
y avait une reprise et souvent c'était
le le le le petit capital initial et on
entrait dans le mécanisme du crédit avec
un apport là là ça vaut zéro et pire que
non en fait c'est pas zéro parce
qu'après il y a plein de Gus qui vont se
mettre en route parce que le schéma est
tellement dément que c'est 12 millions
admettons que l'action des gueux ne
marche pas admettons qu'on échoue et qu'
réussisse à ficeler tout le monde à
terme ils vont le faire par étape parce
qu' le ça veut dire que les 12 millions
de véhicules réputé à mettre au rebut où
ils vont aller en Afrique et oui ils
vont aller chez plus guux que nos gu ils
vont aller en Bulgarie en Europe
centrale en Afrique et c'est là où le
schéma est complètement dément si on si
on parle de la
planète on se fout de notre gueule
en vrai on se fout dans
gue maintenant que tu le découvres ouais
mais à ce pointl ENF je parce que le
même moteur s'il est en
Bulgarie ça reste le globe donc en fait
ça produit toujours le même
CO2 s'il est au Maroc c'est
pareil donc on se fout totalement de
notre gueule est-ce que tu as essayé de
penser contre toi-même et essayer de te
mettre à la place des écologistes ou des
des des maires qui veulent imposer ou du
président de la République qui veut
imposer de l'air pure au citadins sans
particules sans
bruit ils ont dit mais si on fait pas
les ZFE pour reverdir un peu la
trajectoire de notre économie on renonce
à 3 milliards d'euros par an mais là là
si je t'ai bien entendu on renonce à
entre 30 et 60 milliards d'Uros 65
milliards 65 milliards le tout cumulé
c'est dém c'est on a fl un capital flamb
le français mais qui appartenait pas aux
riches qui appartenait aux
pauvres c'est un truc de dingue et quand
quand quand quand quand tu as essayé de
de de leur expliquer aux politiciens que
bah ça mettait des des gens en bascule
vers la grande précarité que ça allait
les épuiser encore plus qu'ils allaient
avoir une vie encore plus compliquée ils
t'ont regardé avec des yeux écarquillés
ils t'ont dit ne t'inquiète pas on a
fait une étude d'impact même pas non
même pas parce qu'en fait il y avait pas
d'étude d'impact
donc quand je vais voir des copains é
cololos de la ville de Paris et que je
pu en plus je pense à quelqu'un que
j'aime beaucoup et je lui dis un je
t'aime deux tu es Dingo et je pense que
tu cours le risque à un moment ils
viennent vous chercher avec des
pics physiquement oui ah ben non mais je
pense que tu cours des risques costaud
et si tu vas pas parler avec euh
avec ta copine la mère de Paris anid
Delgo si tu arrives pas à la convaincre
qu'elle doit aller s'excuser de tout
urgence au
20H ça va très très mal se terminer pour
ces gens-là et ils ne s'en rendent pas
compte parce que c'est ils sont sur le
deck du Titanic donc ça continue à
chanter mais l'iceberg a déjà pété la
coque parce que le pays on est en train
de lu d'exercer une telle violence alors
pour l'instant cette violence elle est
encore contenue parce que les appareils
photos sont en cours d'installation de
lecture les radars qui liront les plaque
c'est en cours d'installation ils sont
pas encore tous branchés et il reste une
trouille dans le
politique de les allumer mais de temps
en temps comme la loi elle est lancée il
y a le 15 février il y a eu sur Twitter
sur X il y a une sous-préfette de Lyon
qui s'est pris en photo avec plein de
gens arme pour dire on purifie l'air
regardez on fout des PV à tout le monde
là la
fille la fille
elle s'est fait un peu vilipander sur
les réseaux s fait un jurier dans des
proportion extraordinaire normalement un
poste d'une sous-préfè ça fait 22 vues
et là je crois que c'était plus de
700000 et je me suis demandé si elle
avait absolument résolument décidé
d'allumer la guerre civile euh de son
propre chef mais en fait la fille elle
faisait qu'appliquer son boulot parce
que maintenant la mécanique elle est
lancée et vous pouvez on peut pas en
même temps reprocher
à à des préfets et des sous-préfets
d'appliquer la loi
votée donc tout ça est on est dans une
situation de qui
vive
d'observation et de mobilisation des
élus locaux parce que tous ces guux ils
sont dans les conseil municip
donc il sont très présents dans la vie
politique donc c'est en train de monter
au cerveau de tous les maires alors à
part les illuminés qui veulent à tout
prix virer et qui rêvent au fond et
après je vais répondre à la
question et qui ont des des
populations
cela je pense à un député de Paris par
charité je veux pas donner son nom qui
me dit mais enfin il faut me comprendre
Alexandre j'ai 80 3 % de mes électeurs
qui n'ont pas de voiture donc l'air pur
pour
eux je lui ai dit il y en a plusieurs
qui m'ont dit ce genre de chose je lui
ai dit je suis désolé j'ai cru que tu
étais député de la
nation j'avais pas compris que tu avais
un petit commerce et que tu servais tes
clients donc ces élus des
centrevillees ils servent leur petits
clients et en fait c'est
exactement ces grandes métropoles qui
sont en train de faire sescessions
gettoisé oui et qui sont en train de
faire sécession et qui demandent au fond
à leur politique bah d'organiser la
sécession et la ZFE c'est
ça c'est le moment de bascule et
l'énorme conflit politique qu'on est en
train d'engager et que nous devons
gagner parce que sinon c'est la
République qui s'est
c'est vraiment un conflit entre une
nation qui est virée par des élites qui
font scession je dis des élites parce
que se perçoivent pas comme ça les gens
à Paris mais par rapport au niveau de
vie de mon village ils sont dans la
stratosphère le prix du mètre carré le
prix du loyer prix du café prix du café
oui on prend un café un croissant pour
un repas le prix d'un repas dans
donc je peux te couper une seconde
est-ce que tu en as profité pour
regarder les chiffres de grande
précarité en France est-ce que tu as
regardé le seuil de pauvreté à combien
il commence combien a de personnes qui
sont autour du seuil de pauvreté combien
il y a de personnes qui vivent avec
moins de 954 € par mois moins de 1200 €
par mois est-ce que tu as regardé ces
chiffres qui indiquent un pays en
souffrance ben je me je suis arrêté
principalement après j'en ai vu mais il
y en a qu'un qui qui m'a
vraiment qui s'est mis entre mes deux
yeux c'est 25 % dans le rouge à la
banque régulièrement le 15 du mois le 15
du
mois donc ça veut dire que ces gens ont
des dépenses contraintes parce que c'est
pas il flamment pas donc ils ont des
dépenses contraintes de logement pour
bouffer leurs
enfants avec de l'ultra minimum ils sont
dans ils sont dans le rouge et on est en
train de venir avec des ZFE et de leur
dire enfin vous fait de la brioche
gâteau oui Marie-Antoinette
MarieAntoinette on est en train de leur
dire ça ça c'est mal terminé hein oui
plutôt donc ça peut très très mal se
terminer et et et après on va aborder
comment
j'envisage que ça
finisse pas en boucherie mais en en en
en en progrès démocratique parce que je
suis foncièrement républicain et
foncièrement démocrate
et la très bonne nouvelle dans ce
chaos ENF avant que je parle des bonnes
nouvelles je vais quand même dire ce que
les mauvaises les mauvaise c'est que moi
je pensais que avec un peu de un peu de
médias un peu parce qu'au bout d'un
moment il y a il y a des gens dans dans
dans les chaîn info qui m'ont invité à
chaque fois je disais mais pourquoi vous
m'initez invitez les politiques
responsables de ça et et et les rchef me
disait on les invite mais ils veulent
pas venir et et il a avant qu'on
commence à voir les premières interview
du maire de Lyon
les il y en a une sur Sud Radio où le
journaliste le pousse et lui dit mais
vous êtes d'accord pour [__] des PV il
dit oui la loi et la loi vous êtes
contre la
loi le dingue qu mais il a mis des mois
parce qu'il devait sentir qu'
allit passer à la
casserole donc pendant tout ce temps-là
les politiques se fauilent mais là
euh à force de pression euh évidemment
le le le je dis le oui le rassemblement
national a déposé
une une propos une PPL une proposition
de loi
d'abrogation les autres ont commencé un
peu à bouger le Sénat a bougé très très
vite parce qu'ils sont liés au maire
donc il y a eu tout de suite assez vite
Vincent louau qui est qui est un
sénateur paysan qui qui a
embarqué une cinquantaine de sénateurs
eux ils veulent voter il me dit il y a
probablement une majorité au
Sénat ce qui ce qui est assez logique
parce que c'est
proche ils sont l'expression du
territoire mais à l'Assemblée là on
tombe dans le jeu des partis et le vrai
problème c'est qu'ils ont tous trempé
là-dedans c'est que en 2019 19
c'est le maire du Havre qui est premier
ministre édard Philippe Philippe c'est
lui qui porte la loi il y en a partout
sur les réseaux où on le voit bénir les
NFE les macarons qui vont commencer à
trier les
gens ça c'est
Hollande et puis la loi de 2021 là c'est
toute la macronie qui va gimment avec
et le monde socialiste enchanté tout ça
les mairies la mairie de Paris les écol
en gros tout le monde a trempé la
et je dis bien
tremper parce que ça s'est fait c'est un
acte de mépris
social ils ont imaginé un monde pour
eux pour ces fameux 83 % plus de
bagnolle et qui au fond on les aime pas
on veut pas les voir et on va les mettre
un peu plus loin même en terme de
sécurité publique c'est pas plus mal
qu'ils a plus de bagnoolle pour qu'il
puisse plus trop s'approcher en fait un
truc de
malade on a bien vu pendant le le
confinement que c'est la France la qui
est en première ligne les plus précaires
qui faisaient tourner le pays c'est une
déconnexion totale de la réalité
économique des capital alors ceux-là ils
sont ils sont impactés au plus ha pour
une raison simple c'est que les gens de
première ligne ils ont des horaires
décalés une infirmière ça démarre pas à
9h du matin c'est des horaires parce
qu'un hôpital ça tourne tout le temps
donc même s'il y a des transports en
commun ils peuvent pas ils ne peuvent
pasiste chez Amazon qui est en hire
décalé qui travaille à 20 km all 20
kmetour donc tous ceux qu'on a bénni
encensé pendant covid sont les plus
impactés
et la grande réponse mais prenez les
transports en
commun ça fonctionne pas pour eux et la
ruralité c'est presque 40 % du pays et
là l'idée que dans la ruralité il y aura
des bouches de
métro et franchement un truc de l'ordre
de la démence donc mais franchement de
la haute démence donc donc alors il
disent oui mais on va on va améliorer OK
et c'est pas fait et puis même améliorer
c'est un point de vue de jeune la
vieille dame comment elle va chez
Carrefour
ou chez auchamp chez
Mamou qui on
veut chez Leclerc chez Leclerc qu'est-ce
qu'elle fout elle va pas revenir en bus
en portant ses pques de lait peut
pas et puis quand on parle des des des
transports en commun euh je prends de
temps en temps la ligne du rordd tu es
courageux le soir mais il y a plus une
fille accessoirement c'est la moitié du
peuple donc dans certaines
zones la
réponse du transport en commun Lig d ça
veut rien dire avant avant que tu me
réexpliques la réaction et la perception
des politiques est-ce que tu sais
pourquoi les quartiers riches à Paris
sont à l'ouest et les quartiers pauvres
sont
histoir de vent de pollution donc le
riche se mettait du bon
côté mais
d'ailleurs ça veut dire aussi qu'on
prend sur la figure les
ventest qui nous amè d'Allemagne avec le
charbon le charbon et de Pologne ou et
de de toute l'Europe
centrale car nos chers écolos allemands
qui n'ont pas voulu de nucléaire nous
flan charbon en pleine
narine donc après on a quand même des
problèmes je suis pas en train de dire
qu'il y en a pas mais on ne peut pas
tenter de les résoudre avec un spectre
illibéral un spectre non
républicain reviens sur la perception
des politiciens que tu as côtoyé ou a
discé lorsque je vais voir des gens par
exle la de Paris je lesou coup je dis
mais enfin merde je te connais tu es
vraiment de gauche je connais ton père
c'est un mec du Parti communiste comment
tu t'arranges dans ta tête
en vrai pour virer les pauvres tu es
tranquille tu tu vis bien
ou oui on aurait dû mieux
préparer et je donc ça veut dire qu' on
abroge et on reprépare
ah non non non non non non non non on
doit garder donc en fait là en ce moment
ils sont en train d'essayer dericoter
pour garder le cadre légal de pression
qu'on peut réactiver à tout moment mais
ils veulent conserver et là il y a une
offensive de
Macron parce que ça gagné du terrain il
y a eu une un amendement qui a été voté
dans une
commission de l'Assemblée
nationale pour que ce soit présenté en
plainère la semaine
prochaine pour que ce soit
éventuellement
voté ement le
9 donc apparemment on s'est dit tiens
peut-être que ça se débloque offensive
du Macron Macron du parti ou du du du du
président ouii qui qui nous fait
débouler via le
trésor hier soir ou ou ce matin une note
disant que si les ADFE sont
abolis ça ça remet en question des des
fonds européens des fonds européens et
on va perdre des milliards combien
TR
donc ça remet en question le le le plan
de relance européenne
donc tout ça est à destination des
députés histoire de bien les les
stresser première étape il y a eu
partout dans un certain nombre de médias
on a fait croire que le vote
de de l'amendement c'était l'abrogation
des AFE histoire de démobiliser tout le
monde ça a pas marché parce que nous on
on a remis des la gomme et et et
dimanche ce dimanche le le dimanche 6
avril vont avoir lieu d'énormes
rassemblements des motards des moturs en
colère les motards c'est parmi ceux qui
savent se mobiliser en France donc si
vous allez sur mon compte X ou sur leur
sur leur site les moteurs en colère vous
allez voir lesmobilisations toutes les
villes c'est à 14h euh à 14h et on a
invité tous les citoyens à venir on peut
venir avec nos gueules de Gueux oui on
peut venir avec nos gueules de guux on
peut venir on peut venir en famille on
peut venir avec honneur parce qu'il
s'agit de servir un pays et des valeurs
très hautes c'est pas rien la
République liberté égalité fraternité
c'est écrit sur nos mairies et on n'est
pas prêt à transiger du tout avec ça
donc c'est extrêmement républicain et ce
qui est sublime c'est que les motards
ont décidé de se battre pas que pour eux
et pour notre pays
c'est vraiment émouvant quand on fait
les réunions avec les moteurs parce que
ils sont habitués à défendre leur petit
précarré et en plus je vais vous dire il
y a plein de zfeu qui qui sont en train
d'essayer de les acheter pour qu'ils se
mobilise pas en leur disant oui mais on
va vous donner des petits
avantages histoire de
désamorcer c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer à à Montpellier par
exemple donc il reste mobilisé
euh pour les autres même si eux ont
commencé à négocier des trucs pour eux
il y a encore des gens qui ont le sens
de la République et
dimanche on va faire des manifestations
autour d'eux statiques pour que les
piétons les guux puissent venir il y
aura je pense beaucoup d'artisans parce
que les artisans c'est une catastrophe
pour eux les adfeux tous ceux dont les
métiers supposent de porter des charges
ils vont pas venir en métro avec le
échelles avec
leur il y aura également probablement
des forains parce que c'est la mise à
mort du monde forain donc de la culture
populaire et des cirques parce que les
cirques ils vont pas changer les camions
et très souvent ils ont des véhicules
qui sont adapté pour les attractions
donc ça c'est clairement la mise à mort
de toute cette culture populaire qu'on
va retrouver alors est-ce qu'ils vont se
mobiliser dès dimanche où est-ce que ça
aura lieu dans les autres mobilisations
je pense qu'il faut à
fond mettre la pression donc reviens à
Macron Macron qui s'empare du dossier
fait circuler du Trésor comme quoi ça va
nous coûter 3 milliards par an de
subvention europé tout monde alors que
l'impôt sur les guux c'est nous on a
calculé à peu près 30 milliards mais tu
me dis 65 milliards c'est énorme c'est
énorme donc Macron il nous fait quoi là
il nous fait une petite macronie nous
fait veut que son projet européen green
soit mené jusqu'au bout si on parle
anglais on parle français pardonou parce
que ça s'appelle comme ça s'appelle
green oui ah c'est beau et et
et or moi je pense que quand j'étais
petit je te rassure tu es toujours petit
j'ai fini quand même par devenir un
vieux
monsieur mais quand quand j'étais gamin
les
écolos tout le monde se foutait un peu
d'eux ils étaient pas considérés ils
faisaient leurs AMAP dans les coins ils
avaient des P qui gratte et puis un jour
les élites françaises se sont rendus
compte qu'elles pouvaient utiliser
l'écologie comme un instrument de
pouvoir au fond les élites al il y a un
truc les intéresse quand elles peuvent
en faire un élément de
taxe de relégitimation des appareils des
bureaucratique parce que tout à coup le
projet européen est même devenu un
projet green un projet
vert alors que au début l'Union
européenne c'était pas ça et et et ça
relégitime les ponctions
fiscales ça ça redéfinit le sens d'un
état assez contrôlant voir hyper
contrôlant avec une idéologie très cool
peace and love l'air l'air pur respirons
ne remons surtout pas en question
comment les voitures chinoises sont
faites le le le charbon allemand le
charbon polonais non donc on donc on est
dans la
folie on est clairement dans
l'instrumentalisation d'une écologie qui
n'appartient pas à ses
abrutis je suis quelqu'un qui préfère
des solutions écologiques mais dans
l'hyper respect de l'être humain alors
comment que tu analyses toi encore avec
tes yeux d'enfant tes yeux purs comment
tu analyses le fait qu'ils y aent au
pied de biche c'est une fuite en avant
alors mis à part qu' se serait emparé du
contrôle du moins de l'écologie pour
pouvoir imposer un contrôle ou de
relégitimiter les relégitimiser les
institutions comment tu analyses ça dans
un contexte plus globalisé de tension
énergétique de de pénurie de ressources
du ou ou de de difficulté à avoir des
ressources à un bon marché de guerre
économique comment toi tu analyses ça
c'est dans l'aire du temps c'est on va
être obligé d'y passer c'est-à-dire que
Al ils sont convaincus euh ils sont
absolument convaincu là je pense qu'il y
a pas que du cynisme ils sont à peu près
convaincus qu'il y a un sens de
l'histoire qu'il y a des choses fatales
qu'il faut en passer par là et que la
démocratie ça passera derrière il le
pense vraiment ils se rendent compte des
répercussions en terme de vote que ça
peut avoir alors non c'est ça qui est
très fascinant parce que j'ai commencé à
faire des réunions euh plusieurs fois
dans un un café en face de Assemblée
nationale on appelant des députés que je
connaissais sans leur dire qu'ils
avaient rendez-vous avec des gens
d'autres groupes ils
arrivent et et et à chaque fois je leur
dis la même chose je le dis est-ce qu'
vousce que vous avez encore deux petits
neurones qui fonctionnent parce que vous
êtes en train vous semblez avoir la
mission est-ce que vous l'assumez cette
mission d'envoyer 24 millions de
Français au rassemblement national si
c'est votre objectif politique
dites-le quelle réaction il y a alors là
il me parl de leur boutique ah oui mais
tu te rends pas compte parce que au sein
de LR au sein du Parti socialiste au
sein truc chez Renaissance on
voit il parl de leur problème d'interne
de de boutique ça me fout en pétard
parce que je leur rappelle qu'ils sont
des élus de la
nation et non pas des des défenseurs de
boutique
et et dans une de ces réunions il y
avait deux deux lascars jeunes sympas
qui rentrent qui m'avit vu dans
le à travers les baes vitrées qui
rentrent qui me disent ouais monsieur
jardin les guux et tout c'est génial on
est avec vous machin et ils ont laissé
deux
cartes de de cartes de visite euh ils
sont partis sympa truc je regarde C deux
députés du RN qui sortait également de
l'assemblée qui était en face
et j'ai montré les deux cartes aux
autres aux autres et j'uris dit je vais
vous les
laisser je vais vous laisser méditer et
puis vous allez voir vos patrons les
chefs de groupe alors depuis que j'ai
commencé à faire ça ça a quand même
infusé et
doucement il y a de plus en plus de ma
et je pense que c'est pas étranger à
tout ça
qui viennent qui
disent on est avec vous il y a de plus
en plus de présidents de région on est
avec
vous on est contre les
AFE ce qui est très extraordinaire c'est
que l'intuition que j'ai eu au début
c'est qu'il fallait faire une alliance
des gu avec les maires et les grands
élus locaux français qui ne peuvent pas
être déconnectés parce qu'il gèent les
gens
est en train de se réaliser et très
rapidement au tout début j'aiétis en
parler avec David Lisnard le président
des Mair de France et je lui ai dit il
faut venir avec moi sur les
plateaux j'ai compris qu'il était contre
mais vraiment viscéralement contre et je
lui dit il faut venir avec moi sur les
plateaux parce qu'il faut que les
Français voient que le président des
maires de France est avec
eux il faut envoyer ce signal
politique parce que ma stratégie c'est
que
je pensais bien que le système d'en haut
allait se rédire donc je pense qu'il y
aura un clash monumental est-ce que ça
va dégénérer à partir de dimanche est-ce
que ça va dégénérer après l'échec très
probable du vote de la loi d'abrogation
la semaine prochaine où là le pays va
vraiment pas bien le prendre peut-être
que les médias nationaux vont pas s'en
rendre compte mais les gens qui sont
impactés par ça quand ils vont
comprendre à quelle sauce ils vont se
faire bouffer euh ils vont pas bien du
tout le prendre reven à Macron donc
Macron qui veut donc donc avant les
maires les les maires les présidents de
région ils arrivent et ce que je leur
dis c'est en cas de
révolte
probable je veux qu'on fasse un tour de
table de grands élus et qu'on donne un
cadre de grands élus et d'association de
maires de Mair ruraux de et pour qu'on
donne un cadre à cette cette révolte
pour qu'il y ait des interlocuteurs avec
l'État et qu'on puisse faire avancer ce
qui me paraît fondamental un
rééquilibrage de la démocratie
représentative par de la démocratie
directe c'est je veux pour notre peuple
un référendum d'initiative citoyenne à
la Suisse structuré avec des sessions
chaque année et je découvre en parlant
avec ces présidents de région avec ses
grands élus euh ses présidents de de de
de d'association départementale de mer
que ils sont tous d'accord ils sont tous
d'accord pour leurs élus ou ils sont
tous d'accord parce qu'ils ont peur pour
leur boutique non ils sont tous d'accord
parce qu'ils sont conscients parce
qu'ils gèrent un petit lopin de France
ils sont tous conscients qu'en face de
l'État central bureaucratique et de et
de et de la folie européenne normative
ils sont devant des bureaucraties qui
vont devoir affronter avec des outils
républicains avec des outils
démocratique donc il y a une prise de
conscience accélérée en ce moment chez
nos élus locaux qu'il faut travailler
avec avec les
guux et que cette alliance là elle
pourra à un moment négocier quelque
chose qui ressemblera à un rééquilibrage
de notre démocratie et pour que ce soit
encore plus clair j'ai publié un livre
Les guux qui parle de ça tu en a vendu
combien alors c'est très simple ils en
avaient tiré 18000
cétait sur le marché jeudi dernier tout
a été vendu avant le vendredi le samedi
matin
9h20 4,50 4,50 € tu prends zé dessus non
non non non non c'est très important que
je gagne ma vie même très peu combien tu
prends je prends je 12 % mais je prends
presque rien mais c'est très important
parce qu'il faut que je reste autonome
et que je reste indépendant on essayé de
t'acheter non on a essayé de te
corrompre non parce que je pense que on
a essayé de te faire comprendre que tu
allais avoir un contrôle fiscal non pas
encore de de de
mais j'ai trouvé un éditeur ce qui était
pas facile qui acceptait Michel Laffond
qui a accepté de de vendre ce livre 4,90
€ alors que le son vrai prix c'était
plutôt 10
€ normalement et j'ai dit non je veux un
prix de guux je veux je veux qu'on parle
au peuple
et et donc là il a été complètement en
rupture tout le weekend là maintenant il
retire des quantités énormes sur Amazon
il était numéro 1 au moment où il est
tombé parce qu'il y avait plus rien donc
dans les listes vous le verrez 13 12
parce qu'il y en a plus mais dès que
maintenant on va inonder ça va être un
rat de marée et ce qui m'intéresse c'est
que c'est un rat de marée qui est utile
aux gens c'est qu'ils vont voir leur
mère avec le bouquin et le fil à leur
mère
ou ils le mettent ils le donneent à
quelqu'un ou ils le mettent dans les
boîtes à livres
euh ça veut dire que je leur demande sur
les réseaux de pas le garder c'est un
livre qui doit circuler ça fait 48 pages
on peut le lire une demi-heure euh et
j'explique
là-dedans comment ça marche les ZFE
comment vous allez vous faire bouffer
comment on en est arrivé à un délire
pareil et comment on peut faire pour que
ça revienne plus et comment on peut
faire pour que ça revienne plus c'est de
devenir une démocratie d'adultte comme
les Suisses je peux te couper là si je
me fais l'avocat du diable je me dis
voilà il y a Alexandre Jardin qui est en
train d'allumer une révolte en France il
est en train de canaliser une révolte en
France il est en train d'instrum
canaliser
ou il est en train d'instrumentaliser
une révolte en France il faut le mettre
sur écoute parce qu'on sait pas ce qu'il
va nous faire s'il va appeler ses
copains agriculteurs qui vont monter à
la capitale pour nous mettre
un petit orage audessus de nos têtees
est-ce que tu as pensé à ça non sinon on
le fais
pas en terme de vie privée tu fais
comment pour protéger ta vie privée tuas
un VPN tu fais attention à tes cookies
j'ai un fils qui me dit de mettre un VPN
je vais le
mettre On dit bonjour à robinon oui
robinon mais
je me sens pas menacé parce que je vais
dire un truc tout bête en venant ici on
m'arrête tout le temps dans la rue on me
dit lâchez pas on l'a vu c'est dingue ça
se fait comme ça donc je sais que la
population comprend ce qu'on est en
train de faire je sais qu'on reste un
peuple de culture républicaine
foncièrement c'est les ruptures
d'égalité c'est un truc qui passe pas
quoi en
France mais ça passe pas du
tout c'est pas du tout dans nos dans
notre imaginaire c'est pas possible
comment tu analyses que Macron soit
monté au créneau c'est pour récupérer de
du pouvoir de la fermeté de la
crédibilité je pense que si on détricote
les ZFE on
détricote énormément de chos et
notamment au niveau européen donc parce
que ça fait partie des des des grands
projets ultra normatifs européens
et c'est drôle parce que il y a 2
semaines il y avait un très grand
article sur les guux dans le Times et
j'ai demandé au journalistes anglais je
dit mais pourquoi vous qu'est-ce qui
vous intéresse là-dedans et il m'a dit
en gros on a les mêmes connards nous on
a les mêmes trucs on a les mêm reprise
en main de la
société les mêmes rapports de pouvoir et
vous vous français vous êtes de cultur
révolutionnaire nous pas c'est pas dans
notre imaginaire dans notre histoire
faites le boulot pour les peuples
européens mettez àat ce truc donc je
sais que Macron le sait que l'enjeu
français il est pour
l'Europe c'était marrant de voir cet
anglais qui qui m'a dit pourtant ils
sont sortis mais ils ils ont conservé
les mêmes systèmes d'hypercontrôle
social
euh disant à un moment e les Français
faites faites votre votre boulot
historique on va peut-être se faire
taper trois fois plus dessus à cause de
ça parce que si on commence à faire
sauter ce type de loi de ségrégation
sociale euh bah ça va s'enflammer
partout en Europe même genre oui ouai
bien sûr bien sûr mais ça a toujours été
comme ça en France est-ce qu'on t'a déjà
insulté genre de populiste du pou il y a
une dame dans la rue l'autre jour qui
m'a dit euh je travaillais à la Terrass
d'un café elle me voit est arrivé elle
m'a
dit vous sentez vous sentez le populisme
de gazoil de de
dieszel
euh puis rajouté encore un nom d'oiseau
et
euh je sentais que je sentais qu'il y
avait une une réaction de
peur derrière cette agressivité c'est
marrant parce que je je l'ai dit sur les
réseaux et hier il y a une dame qui qui
je travaille encore dans un café qui
vient vers moi et qui m'embrasse elle me
dit c'est pour compenser la
folle de de euh on est avec
vous et et je pense que les gens savent
très bien qu'il y a pas d'entourloupe
c'est-à-dire que ce que je veux vraiment
faire avec les élus locaux et je veux
que ce soit une répote
républicaine avec des élus avec des
écharpes de des des gens élus par par
mon peuple euh euh à ce moment-là je
sais bien qu'onira pas dans les dérives
populistes parce que ça sera fondamental
républain c'est quoi une dérive
populiste c'est ce que fait
Macron c'estàdire que ce qui est dément
c'est que il y a pas
plus illibéral que les AFE on n pas
besoin d'avoir
Trump et et c'est ce qui fait c'est
qu'on a un état profond qui aujourd'hui
c'est quoi un état profond c'est un état
qui
s'autogouverne je vais prendre je vais
être extrêmement précis la semaine
dernière il y a la semaine dernière je
sais plus où celleavant très récemment
la numéro 2 du secrétariat général du
Gouvernement je vais retrouver son nom
numéro 2 secrétaire générale adjointe du
secrétariat général du gouvernement qui
est qui démissionne et qui prend un job
elle devient numéro 1 secrétaire général
du de du secrétaire général du Conseil
constitutionnel était peut-être
é faite pour ce boulot non il y a que
dans les démocraties libérales où
l'exécutif envoie quelqu'un à lui dans
la cour suprême ça veut dire qu'on passe
on est en
plein
délire c'est d'une gravité mais ça passe
comme ça tout ça est publié au Journal
officiel tout ça est ratifié et encore
mieux celui qui avait le job à la tête
de de du du secrétaire général du
Conseil constitutionnel il part à la
tête de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence jeu de chaise musical les
mêmes se retrouvent avec une apparence
de séparation des pouvoirs c'est très
très grave ce que je dis et ce qui est
très très grave c'est que tout le monde
s'en est
foutu mais c'est qui le
monde notre vie publique n'en a même pas
parlé moi j'ai vu ça j'en revenais pas
pour un démocrate qui croit en la
séparation des pouvoirs c'est
hallucinant bon donc qui dit qu'ils vont
pas bien faire leur travail mais c'est
même pas le sujet c'est même pas une
attaque personnelle ça ne dépend même
pas des individus parce qu'il peu ça
peut être des personnes de qualité c'est
des problèmes de système et et on a
c'est une crise de
système la technocratie française n'est
pas peuplée de Salau
il se réveillent pas le matin en voulant
le le mal des gens c'est pas ça la
plupart du temps ils sont super ils sont
super oui ils sont cool ils sont sympas
j'en connais plein euh mais en revanche
la déconnexion elle est liée à des
systèmes qui leur permettent d'être
déconnectés pourquoi est-ce qu'en Suisse
à la tête des cantons les gens ne sont
pas déconnectés parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils peuvent prendre dans les
dents un un référendum d'initiative
populaire donc ils écoutent ou du moins
ils font semblant ils sont obligés et
quand ils n'écoutent pas et que ça part
dans le décor ils prennent dans les
dents un référendum d'initiative
populaire donc le système s'autocorrige
je peux ouvrir une parenthèse là on voit
la condamnation de Marine Le Pen et son
inigibilité il y a le rassem
rassemblement national et leurs
électeurs qui qui crient à tout va que
c'est pas normal et de l'autre côté on
dit bah voilà la loi c'est la loi et et
le l'électeur l'électeur parti dit bah
il fallait laisser trancher lesé lecteur
dans les urnes quelle est ta position
dans dans dans ce dossier làà c'est
normal c'est pas normal c'était trop dur
c'était pas assez dur c'est la décision
des juges et on ne touche pas une
décision de juge je préfère parce que
mon point de vue privé il a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt mais en revanche mon vrai
point de vue c'est que c'est un problème
beaucoup plus
global beaucoup plus
haut à partir du moment
où on est dans un système où la masse
d'un peuple a le sentiment que ceux qui
sont dans les grosses villes vont les
exclure donc au-delà de cette petite
crise momentanée il y a un problème qui
est beaucoup plus large et pourquoi
est-ce que c'est grave comme événement
parce que ça vient s'insérer dans cette
crise qui est beaucoup plus global c'est
ça le fond du truc donc parce que en soi
ça pourrait être un problème Judici
mais on voit bien que c'est pas un
problème judiciaire c'estàd c'est un
problème judiciaire qui vient prendre un
autre sens dans un monde complètement
déconnecté où il y a une population qui
essaie de dire des choses
et moi je connais plein de villages qui
votent
RN je m vu un
immigré je vais prendre un exemple très
précis qui s'est passé dans mon village
où il y a un vote Ren énorme euh
il y a je crois un an un an et demi euh
toujours à la boulangerie
euh j'apprends
que le maire qui est un fils de Chevrier
a réussi à mettre la main sur un
troupeau de chèvr de 500 chèvres orors
les garigues la peur là-bas c'est le feu
donc il faut nettoyer les sous-bois et
donc tout le monde était très content
d'avoir trouvé un troupeau de chèvre
c'était une super nouvelle bon il a
touché sa subvention européenne euh même
pas non il reçoit au au contraire une
lettre de la préfecture avec un coup de
tampon de l'Office National des Forêts
qui interdit le transfert de
chèvres
interdiction parce que la chèvre était
réputée ne pas distinguer je ne sais
plus quelle plante pissant lit je me
souviens plus du nom de la plante bleu
plutôt que le le le jaune et que il y
avait eu un grand progrès il y avait un
écolo de bureau qui avait jamais vu une
chèvre qui avait décidé qu'il fallait
protéger le piss en lit autre
ch le maire croit que c'est un canular
téléphone à la préfecture et dit mais si
la GAR
brûle plus du tout plus rien c'est
n'importe quoi voyez bien que c'est
n'importe quoi il lui dit ça fait 3000
ans qu'on nettoie le sousbois avec des
chèvres donc l'expérimentation a duré
ans ah non
l'administration écologique c'est
en fait c'est tout ce mépris parce que
lui il est fils de Chevrier on peut pas
lui expliquer un truc qui
sait
mais la technostructure sa et
impose et si il transporte leschèes
c'est
pénal donc tout à coup on rigole
plus ça me paraît tellement extravagant
que je prends mon téléphone je fais une
interview de lui je fous ça sur Facebook
et je dis aux gens qu'est-ce que vous
pensez 1000 messages de condamnation du
préfet et de l'ONF les gens comprenaient
pas une fois que j'ai mon petit sondage
je téléphone à un gars parce qu'on était
dans le sud de Sud Radio je le fais
inviter dans une matinale je dis j'ai un
bon sujet pour
toi la la chèvre regarde sur Facebook et
je dis c'est presque une fable cette
histoire de chè entre la
technostructure et le terrain il passe
il fait un carton il y a un journal
Figaro qui voit ça qui fait une
demi-page le lendemain il m'appelle le
maire affolé il me dit il a il y a un JT
de France 2 et de TF1 demain j'ai jamais
parlé à la télé il faut que tu viennes
je dis surtout pas on va parce que
Alexandre Jardin et les chèvres c'est
pas bon c'est toi qui est bon avec t il
y va et puis c'est ta cause tu vas avec
ton
cœur la préfecture va commencer à
négocier expérimentation sur 150 chèvres
pour vérifier que la plante elle est
survive et rebelote les dossiers et
l'année prochaine rebelote les
dossiers le mépris c'est ça comment on
fait pour reconnecter notre techno
structure nos nos
administrateurs comment on fait pour les
reconnecter avec la vraie France par
celle qui bosse celle qui se lève le
matin par on va pas on va pas tourner
autour il y a qu'une manière c'est la
démocratie directe il y en a une
deuxième mais en général ils l'ont
oublié oui mais celle-là elle régule
tout déjà ce serait bien qu'on
reprennent des députés Mair c'estàd des
gens qui ont sont déjà occupés de
quelqu'un parce que là on a fait des
députés qui qui s'occupent pas des
autres ils s'occupe bien d'eux quand
même non oui ça va oui ils s'occupe de
leur point ils sont pas augmentés là
récemment pour résister à
l'inflation signateur aussi je pense je
pas regarder dans le détail
mais ENF structurellement tout ce qui va
favoriser le transfert
d'expérience du bas vers le haut il faut
qu'on le fasse dans l'éventualité où ils
sont en
cavalerie de lois à légiférer pour Just
leur salaire et ils imposent et Macron
récupère et il
impose si on se retape un mouvement
gilet jaune sous stéroïde en mode gu à
l'ancienne à la française qu'est-ce que
tu vas leur dire vous restez tranquille
vous cassez rien vous montrez que vous
êtes audessus de tout le monde ou tu ne
donneras pas de
consigne d'abord je suis pas d'accord
avec le début de la phrase le
conditionnel il va y avoir la question
c'est est-ce que c'est la semaine
prochaine ou est-ce que c'est au moment
où ils vont allumer les appareils photos
et que les PV vont commencer à tomber
parce que si à Lyon par exemple on
commence à
allumer il y a 2 millions de gueux qui
ont besoin d'aller bosser qui ont besoin
des hôpitaux qui ont besoin de rentrer
dans la ville et qui peuvent pas
transport commun marche pas perdre 2
heures de sommeil pour voil voilà les
heures de sommeil les trucs ENF ils
peuvent pas donc si on commence à
allumer les appareils photos et que les
gens R et que ils ont plusieurs fois 68
€ donc évidemment que ça flambe à ce M
c'est impossible ils peuvent pas vivre
moment il faut qu'ils vivent donc or
s'ils vont au bout de leur truc ben
c'est ça ils sont en train d'installer
les appareils photo hein et
l'intelligence artificielle elle sait
lire la mre de Paris a mis sur le périf
des trucs qui repèent si on est tout
seul caméra thermique caméra thermique B
donc là c'est en cours
d'installation
donc ce que je leur dis c'est
allez-y démerdez-vous
ou est-ce que vous commencez à nous
écouter avant que ce
soit ce soit la
guerre parce que quand on humilie parce
que la question c'est
l'humiliation quand on ne respecte pas
la des
gens le retour de bâton est pas
sympathique est-ce que tu as essayé de
voir ça avec de la bienveillance envers
nos politiciens est-ce que tu as essayé
de voir ça en élargissant le prisme de
lecture en te disant voilà l'Europe la
France est en sevrage énergétique de par
des questions de ressources le pic
énergétique et par des questions
géopolitique du fait qu'on soit fâché
avec les Russes et qu'on est en train de
se fâcher d'autant plus avec les
Américains fournisseurs d'H carbure et
qu'on va fermer nos centrales et que et
l'un comme l'autre et que on on va être
rigé de mettre l'Europe en sevrage
énergétique et qu'il faut préparer nos
gueux aller marcher avec leurs pieds
perdre 2hures de sommeil le matin et
rentrer 2h de so allerer faire marcher
parce que tu comprends quand ils vont se
taper ou quand la France va se taper une
augmentation du cûpt des hydrocarbures
ça fera la même chose donc on essaie un
petit peu de les entraîner on entraîne
nos
guux nous n n nous
ser c'est en tout cas en tant que
Français je suis extraordinairement
français intérêt c'estàdire
universaliste c'est qu'on pense pour
l'homme je la France c'est elle roule
pour l'homme
avant non on va rétablir ça le
le toutes ces difficultés qui existent
on doit à tout prix
le vivre de manière
républicaine on peut pas en passer par
ces expériences autoritaires
que qui pointe le nez avec les ZFE parce
que si on lâche sur les ZFE si on les
combat pas si dimanche il y a personne
si on attend finalement le grand la
grande révolte on s remettra pas il peut
y avoir une
répression mais derrière toutes les
mesures coercitives que vous allez
devoir
bouffer à partir de l'année prochaine si
le gu arrive à changer de bagnole il
aura un coup de bambou parce que il y a
des malus prévus sur les sur les
voitures
d'occasion mais c'est c'est sans fin les
conneries le le mais c'est sans fin les
conneries regarde comment on a rajouté
1000 milliards de dette à la France on a
acheté on a acheté la paix sociale pour
1000 milliards alors tu vas me dire oui
mais il y a eu alors alors non mais moi
je suis quand même très optimiste parce
que je vois je vois les mères venir vers
nous je les
vois sincèrement
à accepter l'hypothèse de d'un
rééquilibrage de de notre démocratie
avec de la démocratie
directe très sincèrement et j'en vois
beaucoup qui me suggèrent des choses qui
ont beaucoup réfléchi qui ont été voir
en Suisse qui
euh qui propose par exemple il y en a
beaucoup qui qui plusieurs qui ont euh
qui m'ont proposé de de faire une
session annuelle en Suisse il y a il y a
parfois trois trois sessions dans
l'année avec des QCM euh c'est très
structuré chez eux euh et qui me disent
euh on pourrait démarrer par une session
annuelle euh pour que le peuple
s'exprime directement je peux te couper
je vais te poser une question qui va pas
te plaire est-ce que tu as pas
l'impression que la démocratie n'est
plus apte à gérer nos sociétés euh alors
qu'elles sont gigantesques exposé a tout
un tas de menaces et surtout que
structurellement parlant la démocratie
fonctionne quand on a des
ressources facilement utilisable non
est-ce que tu as pas l'impression que il
y a partout en Europe et même dans le
monde une réémergence de pouvoir très
autoritaire que une grande partie des
populations demande les carisers un peu
partout oui mais oui mais on n'est pas
n'importe quel peuple on est la France
on est français et et et on est
républicain l'homme vaut quelque chose
de considérable chez nous
donc on va vivre ça à la française c'est
en républicain et en
démocrate et moi je pense que toutes les
difficultés que que tu indiques et qui
qui évidemment n nous
cernent je pense qu'on peut le vivre
avec une hauteur incroyable et qu'on
pourquoi je me casse le cul faire ça je
dire de de de je suis pas obligé de le
faire hein j'ai tu
utopiste
non pas du tout je suis extrêmement
pragmatique avec les maères tu as
soutenu Macron pourtant non non tu as
pas soutenu Macron non non du
tout du tout j'ai été très très intrigué
au début au au moment où où la presse
parlait j'étais le voir c'est c'est
quelqu'un que je connaissais
personnellement à ce moment-là et j'ai
été comme toujours dès que je vois un
truc je vais voir normal et et rien ne
vaut le renseignement de terrain oui et
j'ai très vite
compris que c'est qui rêvait
du d'une prise de pouvoir de la
technocratie pur et dieux des crân d'œuf
et que il y avait un emballage de
électoral qui allait tomber et on a une
grosse fâerie à un moment à la fin parce
que parce que j'étais pas d'accord avec
la tricherie quoi tu lui as dit oui
qu'est-ce qui a répondu il raccroché au
nez on s'est plus parler depuis
euh il a fait il a fait le choix de de
de il n'a jamais adhéré en
marche tout ça était vendu par Ismaël
émélien avec les tableaux et les trucs
je l'ai vu dans le
bureau donc il s'est fait lire avec un
formidable publicitaire qui lu monter
son truc
euh mais en vrai il y a pas eu une prise
de pouvoir de la société civile enfin il
y a il y a rien eu de tout ça d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que son propre
parti se désagrège euh ça a été le
dernier coup de la technocratie
française qui s'est déguisé dans dans
pour repasser mais c'était le secrétaire
général de l'ésée euh je sais plus son
titre adjoint ou je sais plus le le
c'était un type qui était un inspecteur
des finances s'appelle pas Alexis non
colère non il vient de partir
mais et là encore c'est extraordinaire
le le secrétaire général deésée vient de
partir le lendemain il prend un job
fondamental à la Société Générale ça
veut dire que le pouvoir politique toc
devient le pouvoir financier donc là tu
me fais rebondir sur la dette française
est-ce que tu as vu à peu près ce qui
s'était passé en Grèce quand ils ont eu
la troa quand quand ils ont eu le les
EUR les les euros financiers au fess
quand ils ont été obligés de de
privatiser leurs ports leurs aéroport et
j'en pass des
meilleurs tu as pas l'impression que
c'est réellement le pouvoir financier
qui dicte les politiques intérieures
maintenant quand il y a des agences de
notation qui disent attention si on a un
modèle économique qui marche plus et qu'
et qu'on décide de
structurellement avec une impasse
financière énorme de de l'ORD duc oui on
se met entre les mains
mais je rappelle que la France était
dans cette situation en 58 lorsque de
Gaul arrive on avait encore nos colonies
à l'époque non non il était en train de
solder tout ça il était en train de de
de de de régler les problèmes bon mais
également avec le plan RF on s'est
redressé très très vite donc en réalité
on peut se redresser très très très vite
sans matièrees premières sans énergie
bon marché on n avait
pas le le et et puis moi je n'oublie pas
que churchilleld fait la guerre en
allant à la Chambre des communes tout le
temps il fait la guerre c pas évident de
se battre contre
Hitler à ce moment-là il avait un
armement faible mais ils se battent avec
la Chambre des communes en démocrate et
d'ailleurs fin de la guerre il est battu
et il se barre Staline était effaré mais
c'est c'est un démocrate donc tout ce
qu'on doit régler on peut le régler en
démocrate c'est une histoire de choix
humain pourquoi on est plus en en réelle
démocratie maintenant si je t'entends
bien on a la herupper class des des
villes on a les
guux ça va mal se terminer cette
histoire là ben oui les fondamentaux
économiqu son prochaine c'est évidemment
que ça va mal se terminer très très vite
ou bien ou alors la première VAG
desgux aura permis de structurer le
rapport entre les classes populaires et
les élus locaux et au moment où ça
pêtera peut-être si ça pète pas assez
vite ça peut péter 6 mois plus tard
est-ce que tu as vu les l'anticipation
du pouvoir central pour encadrer ce type
de mouvement qui peut se révéler peuvent
pasends attends qui peuvent se se se
révéler profondément violent les achats
de grenades de désencerclement de
fumigène de de C lamogène sitifri sort
du tube on peut pas le contrôler le le
le tu as vu comment on a contrôlé les
gilets jaunes avec des mesures contrein
sur actionnel digne pay du TI mond ou
oui mais le drame des gilets jaunes qui
est un mouvement que j'ai connu au
départ à à sa naissance le drame c'est
que sur les rond-points personne ne
voulait être représenté la haine de la
représentation était telle que il y
avait une
impossibilité de d'avoir des
interlocuteurs pour
l'État c'est pour ça que moi j'ai tout
les pourquoi j'ai été voir David lnard
tout de suite je d mais parce qu'il faut
qu'on fasse la jonction tout de
suite pour qu'on rédite pas la même
connerie et et comme on est des
démocrates les ma ils tombent pas du
ciel ils sont élus le ma de mon village
il est élu
donc donc tout de suite j'ai compris
qu'on devait faire l'alliance des
gu des
comment tu vois la France à 5
ans est-ce que tu vois le taux de
pauvreté exploser est-ce que tu nous
vois en guerre est-ce que tu nous vois
avec un nouveau président de la
République qui est-ce que tu nous vois
avec comm au Brésil des favéas non pas
du tout pas du tout j'ai une confiance
illimitée dans nos
capacités mais
illimité sinon je ferai pas ça
quand on est démocrate c'est on a
foncièrement l'amour de l'intelligence
de l'autre sinon on n'est pas démocrate
donc j'ai j'ai une en plus j'ai monté un
premier mouvement qui s'appelait bleu
blanc zèbre mouvement des zèbres
qu'est-ce que c'était on on rassemblait
les gens qu'on appelait des feuseux les
feuseux c'était soit des associations
soit des entrepreneurs soit des maires
je me foutais complètement de la nature
juridique du du de l'opérateur c'était
quelqu'un qui prenait une une fracture
sociale et qui la réglait et qui
obtenait des
résultats bleu blancz vient de de mettre
la clé sous la porte mais c'est pas
grave ce qui est important c'est le
fichier c'est les 300 mouvements qui
sont
dedans ce sont des équipes qui savent
créer euh des orchestres symphoniques
dans des
cités un éditeur comme lire s partir
c'est vendre 6 millions d'exemplaires
hors marché du livre dans dans les cités
dans les banlieux et dans les
campagne donc il s'est réglé we moove
est est un des plus extraordinaires
outils français pour trouver des
solutions de transport pour les chômeurs
longue durée pour qu' c'est la
principale difficulté c'est le transport
quand on est au chômage depuis longtemps
on a vendu sa bagnole donc même si on
est ouvrier platrier et qui a un
chantier à 20 km si on n pas un véhic on
peut pas y aller
règle ces problèmes là donc quand on a
pris le temps comme moi pendant des
années de regarder la créativité du pays
on a une vraie
confiance parce qu'on a des équipes qui
le font tout ça on a des maires qui
savent tripler leur population en zone
rurale au fond des vauges parce qu'ils
ont des modèles de développement mais ça
ne n'est pas dans la tête des crân Deuf
ça n dans de l'intelligence profonde de
ce pays
c'est pour ça que je suis aussi
démocrate c'est je sais que dès qu'on va
se
régler pour qu'on ne soit
plus
bloqué par notre bureaucratie par la
bureaucratie européenne en défonçant un
certain nombre de choses par nos
référendum on va reprendre le lit en
Europe est-ce qu'il faut sortir la
France de
l'Europe on va pas évaporer les autres
mais ils sont là on vit avec eux bon ils
vont pas déménager on va pas
déménager mais il y a un truc qui est
sûr sûr sûr et certain c'est que le
fonctionnement actuel complètement
horors sol complètement bureaucratique
n'est juste pas possible bah ça a l'air
de bien marcher regarde
non je dire on a effondré notre
automobile on a effondré notre énergie
effondré notre agriculture effondré euh
effondré effondré effondré donc ça
marche pas l'approche bureaucratique qui
est derrière le schéma actuel européen
ne marche pas ça marche pas mais ça
marche quand même regarde on fait de la
dette à gogo la France
emprunte pratiquement 1 milliard par
jour
ou mais on joue avec le feu quoi la
France emprunte pratiquement
l'équivalent de oui mais 11 millions de
barils par jour non mais les intérêts de
la dette française sont supérieurs à la
consommation d'hydrocarbures journaliers
française le prix des intérêts oui mais
on va devoir sortir de ce truc et
comment en redevenant une démocratie en
reprenant des décisions possibles
raisonnables je sais pas pourquoi je
suis autant confiance en
nous mais sinon je ferai pas
ça est-ce que tu as été approché pour te
faire intégrer dans un parti politique
non européen on t'a pas proposé un petit
siège mais on t'a pas proposé des
valises de
billets je pense que ça viendra jamais à
l'esprit de personne tu as laissé une
lettre au cas où que tu es un
accident mais non je me sens pas en
danger dans mon
pays pour ça qu'on a pas pris ARD
Snowden on lui a pas proposé l'asile
je pense que ça va bien se passer mais
que ça va être chahuté ce qui va
arriver et je pense que cette classe
politique locale je connais très bien
elle sait vivre par par gros temps et
par tempête c'est pas des politiques en
chambre tu vois gabrielal Stéphane
séjourné voir vivre par gros temps non
pas eux mais je parle des élus
locaux ils savent parler jaou il sa'est
parl à la rue de son village il parle
très très bien avec les gens les les
Lisnard à Cann il sait parler aux gens
tous les grands-mères
français ils savent parler aux gens donc
on a on a une classe républicaine et de
culture
républicaine d'assez grande qualité
est-ce que tu as essayé de te mettre à
la place des gens qui vivent en
ville et que bah ils se prennent des des
part particu du CO2 qu'ils ont un air
pollué et que bah c'est
difficile tu leuras s viennent te voir
en disant voilà mon cancer pulmonaire ça
vient de des gu ça vient des
pauvres et bien moi je pense que tout le
monde je vis par moment dans le centre
de Paris je préfère respireer
bien mais je je pense qu'en plus c'est
du populisme de faire croire que c'est
les pauvres c'est du populisme ils sont
en train de nous fourguer un truc de
populiste au vrai sens du terme c'estàd
qu'ils sont en train de faire de la
démagogie électoraliste en essayant de
choper leur propre électorat de
centreville les les c'est ils sont en
train de faire un truc qui est CCRA
parce que c'est pas ça qui va sauver les
poumons de qui que ce soit d'abord parce
que l'essentiel des particules viennent
du chauffage l'essentiel des particules
viennent des vents de l'est donc donc à
un moment travaillons sérieusement sans
démagogie en regardant pour de vrai mais
certainement pas en virant les pauvres
je dire mais même dans le centre-eville
je dire mais merde je connais beaucoup
de gens à Paris il y a personne je
connais personne en vrai qui souscrit et
qui signe quand je si je lui dis tu es
d'accord pour qu'on purifie l'air des
riches en virant les pauvres
c'est Marreau c'est gredin oui mais
c'est pas possible il y a personne en
vrai qui veut
ça c'est pour ça que ils vont perdre
question internet Alain damazio
n'avait-il pas anticipé dans les furtif
les a et feux avec la ségrégation
spatiale dans son livre il parle des
quartiers accessibles via un forfait
privilège prémium ou standard les
quartiers réservés au forfaits
privilégiés et Premium sont des espace
de luxe et de confort tandis que les
autres habitats sont relégués à des
zones démunies et mal entretenu que
pense votre
invité il faut lire Damasio c très sympa
en plus oui mais
mais mais ce qui est drôle c'est qu'au
moment où Damasio a écrit ça ça semblait
un peu de la SF quoi non on l' reçu
juste au même moment parce que on a vu
que c'était pas de la SF c'tait de la
prospective et ben je vais être franc
quand je lisais
ça j'y croyais pas je me disais quand
même l'être humain est pas con à ce
point j'ai toujours dans l'idée qu'il va
pas être totalement con j'avais tu sais
l'être humain est quand même sacrément
con il y a eu des génocides en Europe
oui je sais c'est dramatique oui mais
j'ai toujours dans l'idée que je garde
en tête la tête de de de de dans le
chagrin et la pitié qui est un
documentaire de
génial où il y a une interview de Pierre
mades France et à un moment
il dit que il a toujours su que ça se
terminerait que l'enfer de de
l'occupation se terminerait et il avait
raison toi tu tu crois qu'on va arrêter
de se faire occuper là ouais je pense
que dans les situations les pires je on
aurait eu cette discussion à Noël 43 euh
je t'aurais dit il y a plus que 6 mois à
tenir après ces 30 ans assez marrant
avec les Beatles bardau à no 43 tu je
t'aurais dit avant on va tuer du BOSCH
oui oui mais finalement ça s'est fait
assez
vite l'être humain est capable de
changement très
rapide très rapide
euh j'ai toujours été fasciné par ça je
dire le reréglage de 58 il se fait sur 4
3 4 ans on règle nos problèmes coloniaux
on on on se met à jour on règle nos
problèmes financiers on on on se barre
de de de l'influence américaine on fout
les bases américaines dehors on avait
qui comme politicien à l'époque quelle
carure quelle envergure et quelle épaule
mais il y en a plein en France il manque
de courage il manque de quoi non il y en
a plein en
France il y a plein de gens
je est-ce que vous vous rendez compte ce
que ça veut dire pour un petit MRE de
SAB d'aller inverser de reprendre le
pouvoir
le mec le fait le l le
fait fait question internet provoque les
guux ne sont-ils pas des égoïstes avec
un mode de vie polluant et décadant d'
du rêve de la maison individuelle
daffreux qui se chauffe au fi et au feu
de bois au feu de bois les les
cette phrase elle est elle est terrible
parce que évidemment qu'elle est
prononcée avec avec
ironie
mais ce qu'on va devoir [__] par terre
dans tous ces
mouvements à la
française c'est de tourner la page de la
culture du
mépris il y a plein de copains qui m'ont
dit mais tu te rends pas compte tu vas
courir le risque on va te taxer de des
magagogu de
populistes je dire oui on j'aurais
peut-être le droit du mépris mais je
sais qu'on se bat contre le
mépris c'est ça qui doit
reculer cette culture du cette phrase
elle est elle
synthétise mais ce n'est plus possible
c'est
irrespirable c'est le cas de le dire
ouais question Inter le béprix c'est
irrespirable question Internet
comparé à avant les gilets jaunes ou
comment ça va se passer du côté de
l'attitude des policier le jour où ça va
partir en VRI selon
vous c'est pour ça que je veux
lesim ça sera beaucoup plus compliqué de
se conduire mal avec des mouvements
civils
encadrés soutenus par des écharpes
républicaines c'est dur que faire un
headshot sur un mer ça fait CC dans les
compliqué c'est compliqué donc c'est
pour ça mais j'ai bien retenu la leçon
des gilets jaunes
cétait c'est parti en couille après
parce qu'il y avait pas il y avait pas
le cadre de la République et c'est et la
République elle peut entrer en
révolte question internet qui n'est pas
trop une question mais qui a mi question
M commentair pourquoi ne pas faire des
zfer des zones à forte exclusion des
riches à
fe où on interdit au riches de sortir de
chez
eux alors dans l'idée de la manif de
dimanche il faut venir avec sa
déclaration d'impôt c'est ça non tu sais
y a des riches quand même qui sont avec
les contre les évidemmentcasante
majorité
mais j'avais proposé au motur jeais dire
on va encercler les villes qui enferment
pour le montrer ce que ça fait que
d'être enfermé avec les
motos trou ça marrant
[Musique]
symboliquement question internet
pensez-vous que les inégalités de
richesse croissante sont masqué par
l'augmentation des peurs chez les gens
pour éviter de parler de l'accaparement
des richesses par
l'élite que je la relise oui pensez-vous
que les inégalités de richesse
croissante sont masquées par
l'augmentation des peurs chez les gens
pour éviter de parler de l'accaparement
des richesses par l'élite
je crois surtout que les riches ils sont
plus là ils sont barrés de France triche
bah là j'ai passé beaucoup de temps en
Asie dans des vraies zones de
prospérité d'optimiste d'optimisme où là
il y a vraiment des gens très riches
c'est quoi très
riche c'est des gens qui ont des moyens
de faire d'investir c'est ça à hauteur
de millions de dizaines de millions de
centaines de millions en Asie les
fortunes qui se font en ce moment sont
énormes il y a combien de zé à un
milliard je ne sais plus je suis pas
très très bon
làdedans le je comprends même pas
comment j'ai réussi mon diplôme de
Sciences
Po sans savoir 90 sur un milliard c'est
normal que tu es eu ton diplôme
ch
mais non je pense que notre système pour
l'instant ne crée pas de richesse c'est
surtout ça il n'en crée pas c'està-dire
que euh euh il va bien falloir qu'on
recommence à à à à refaire de de la
prospérité populaire c'est très
intéressant ce que tu
dis notre système est bon à produire que
des vieux et des dettes ah oui là pr ça
va plus quoi donc on consomme par jour
en emprunt bah pratiquement SEP fois
plus qu'on qu'on consomme en réel du MO
on produit en dette de la la Magic
monnaie la monnaie
imaginaire 11 fois plus 11,3 million de
barils par jour alors qu'on consomme
un3 donc cette prospérité basée sur une
énergie bon marché c'est foutu pour nous
on va inventer autre chose on va
inventter quoi moi je je suis beaucoup
moins pessimiste que toi sur le frond
pourquoi tu dis que je suis pessimiste
parce que j'ai regardé beaucoup
d'émissions avec des gens pourquoi tu
dis pas que je suis réaliste
des j'ai toujours l'impression que
l'être humain farique de l'inattendu
profond
c'est c'est pour ça
que j'ai écrit un petit livre auquel je
tiens beaucoup qui s'appelle les
magiciens qui est un livre qui est
consacré aux gens qui pensent
différemment et qui ont structuré la
pensée humaine il y en a un notamment
pour pour te répondre qui au 13e siècle
qu'on connait pas en France qui
s'appelle frrich de stofen qui est
l'empere
d'Occident c'est le contemporain de
Saint-Louis sa Saint-Louis apporte rien
il est sous un
chîne Sten va importer en Europe la
science expérimentale arabe il est
arabophone parce qu'il a grandi en
Sicile sur les qu
il une aventure incroyable il reprend
possession du pouvoir très très jeune
avant 20
ans et en tant qu'arabophone il est
conscient que la S expériental à
l'époque se développe dans le monde de
l'Islam et il va importer en Europe des
professeurs dans les universités c'est
un décret impérial il change le mode de
penser de
l'Occident c'est ça un politique
et ça fabrique toute la Renaissance
toute la révolution
industrielle c'est tout ça naî de stofen
mais l'histoire n'est pas écrite n'est
jamais écrite il y a des gens qui
changent de mode de penser
et il y a un petit pays par exemple qui
m'intéresse beaucoup Singapour leur
méthode d'éducation
euh ils pensent très très différemment
tout tu as vu les logements là-bas oui
je je connais mais ils sont très
différents de nous les gens ne pensent
pas comme nous d'ailleurs on pense pas
comme nous les donc je sais que on va
être capable d'énorme
changement quand j'ai écrit les
les les
magicien je sais qu'il y en aura
d'autres
magiciens trom et si tu te trompes
est-ce que tu as essayé de penser contre
toi-même en te disant voà peut-être que
les magiciens on va jamais les voir
peut-être que la propagande étatique
peut-être que les ingérences des lieux
de musque peut-être que les réseaux
sociaux ça va empêcher le changement ou
ça va faire continuer les lignes droites
jusqu'au ciel si ça se passe pas est-ce
que tu as essayé de le de le
matérialiser ou de l'imaginer non j'y
crois
pas tu vas revenir le jour où tu vas
essayerav non mais ça veut pas dire que
ça peut pas être très chaotique mais
mais ce qui peut démarrer la semaine
prochaine ça ça peut être difficile hein
parce que
je je vais pas expliquer tout parce que
mais les mouvements de révolte qui sont
venus me voir il y a pas que des gens
hyper calme il y a les agriculteurs qui
t'ont appelé B tout le monde parle en
France tout le monde parle mais quand
les gens ont accumulé des
humiliations ils ont des raisons de pas
être sympa
euh il y a vraiment des choses qui
doivent être absolument
entendu mais je pense que notre cadre je
pense que ce que je suis en train
d'essayer de construire va tenir la
route dans la tempête est-ce qu'une
greffe générale pourrait faire bouger
les
choses une greffe de
guux j'ai une grande confiance dans les
formes que ça va
prendre franchement
si on m'avait dit que je serais sur sur
une moto avec des bikers dimanche à 14h
devant la mairie de
Paris au Milie d'un monde de
moto ça m'aurait pas semblé crédible
c'est
que j'ai passé du temps par exemple à
parler avec des syndicats moment j' les
voir là c'est les travailleurs qui
peuvent plus rentrer des infirmières qui
vivent en dehors des faut s'en occuper
la base mécoutz d'ailleurs dimanche il y
aura je pense aux gens dans les
structure hospitalière de Rennes par
exemple de la
CFDT qui qui qui sont assez mobilisés et
qui sont très hostile au
ZFE je pense à des gens avec qui j'ai
parlé de de la branche des services au
sein de la
CFDT qui sont très choqués par ce qui
est en train de se passer mais euxmême
ils sont dans les grands systèmes et les
phénomènes de bureaucratisation de de
déconnexion aussi existe dans tous les
grands système en France donc finalement
ça veut dire qu'on démarre avec les
bikers avec les motos question question
qui nous vient de Bulgarie ouais est-ce
que ce monsieur ne surestime pas la
capacité révolutionnaire de la France ce
qui nous permet de nous endormir en
rêvant que l'horreur est temporaire pour
une révolution il faut des jeunes
résilients face à la violence et une
idéologie de remplacement aucune des
cases ne ressemble ne semble rempli chez
vous en Europe de l'Ouest merci à vous
deux est-ce que tu rêve pas une France
d'avant est-ce que maintenant les
Français en fait ils sont en en
catatonie émotionnelle parce qu'ils se
font tabasser d'impôts o il y a des
violences au sein de de de à cause des
tensions économiques il y a des
violences dans le boulot dans leur
couple à l'école dans la rue que avec 25
% 20 25 % d'inflation est-ce que on a
pas un peuple français qui a endormi ses
démons parce que il est démoralisé parce
que il il est déjà en survie à essayer
de payer ses factures de gaz qu'on fait
x 2 depuis
2022 que que il faut 1600 ballle pour
chauffer une barque d'électricité de gaz
de file de bouffe alors mon raisonnement
il est je vais répondre à cette personne
en Bulgarie euh mon raisonnement c'est
que précisément parce que tout ce que tu
dit est vrai il y a un moment où c'est
plus tolérable
et quand on a touché à la
voiture la voiture on a touché à l'accès
au travail donc quand les gens disent
quand j'ai devant moi des des des des
gens très puissants dans l'état et qui
me disent vous croyez qui aura des
gilets jaunes et des trucs je dit mais
vous savez ce que c'est que la voiture
c'est le
travail ils ont des traites à payer sur
leur maison ils ont des enfants pensez
qu'ils peuvent arrêter de travailler
singl ou
quoi donc en réalité si ça vient à terme
leur
projet il ne peut pas y avoir une
situation
calme parce que
mais ce que je trouve très
extraordinaire c'est ce que je leur dis
souvent dans les réunions je leur dis
mais c'est des questions de
bourgeois vous pensez que mais c'est pas
une opinion c'est quand on on a besoin
de bosser pour pour nourrir ses enfants
c'est pas une opinion et quand on vous
empêche c'est pas
possible c'est délirant de penser qu'il
vont rester tranquilles les gens
mais est-ce que vous personnellement
vous resteriez tranquille bien sûr que
non donc évidemment qu'on s'approche de
cette de cette zone et je vais je vais
être encore plus franc je suis très
surpris que le mouvement des guux a pris
cette puissance et rassembler autant de
gens avant que les appareils photo
crépitent est-ce que je vachement
surpris c moi je pensais que on allait
faire les choses mais que ça ne dé
vraiment qu'au moment de la répression
est-ce que est-ce que par exemple en
terme de répression est-ce qu'il y a des
huiles de la gendarmerie ou de la police
qu'on essayé de t'appeler pour te dire
voilà on est d'accord avec toi parce que
nous on se voit pas verbaliser une maman
qui va enemmener s ses gamins à l'école
ou faire ses courses oui et des
militaires aussi aussi l'armée par
exemple évidemment qu'il sont tous tous
d'accord avec
nous pourquoi d'abord parce qu'ils ont
des véhicules de
ils ont été regardé dans les
stocks ils ont pas train de dire qu'on a
une armée de Guu là mais non mais ils
n'ont pas de s'il avait pas les
autorisations exceptionnelles il
pourrait pas aller sur les champs de
manœuvre je sais je sais précisément le
le
le et puis naturellement une armée c'est
c'est proche de son peuple c'est issu de
son peuple et la gendarmerie la police
il t'ont appelé en disant voà nous on se
voit pas verbaliser des pauvres comme
ça j'ai pas envie de mettre des
gens
mais il faut savoir par exemple que dans
la gendarmerie c'est très populaire les
généraux de la gendarmerie ils sont
adorables les gendarmest ce sont des
fils du peuple ce sont des c'est
vraiment la la vraie méritocratie
républicaine et ce sont des gens qui
gèrent du matin jusqu'au soir des
problèmes sociaux il les gère vraiment
donc quand il voit arriver des conneries
mais même au sein de la
préfectorale je vais pas je je vais pas
nommer pour pas les mettre en en mais
quand il y a des mouvements de ma qui
qui essayent de de faire basculer des
des des des
majorités pour être hostile au au au aux
ZFE ils reçoivent parfois des SMS
de de préfet qui dit bravo mais mais
pourquoi parce que ils sont pas tous
givrés donc ils savent bien que ça va ça
peut créer une situation qu'ils ne vont
pas savoir gérer ils sont pas dingues et
puis il y a aussi beaucoup d'humanistes
là-dedans question Internet et
d'ailleurs ça va me faire rebondir sur
une question est-ce raisonnable d'pposer
santé et ZFE alors que les ZFE
n'apportent rien en terme de qualité de
l'air oui alors question est-ce qu'il y
a eu des études sur les les l'impact
d'une positif d'une ZFE mais non parce
que la vraie phase répressive c'est
depuis massive c'est depuis le 1er
janvier donc on a on a un effondrement
de de la pollution en ville qui est lié
à plein de raisons qui n'ont rien à voir
d'ailleurs avec les ZF premièrement
notre parc il se trouve qu'en ville les
gens ont des sous donc c'est là qu'on
achète les voitures donc le
renouvellement du parc se fait
évidemment plus vite dans les zones
urbaines qu'on F des campagnes mais tout
le monde le
voit donc c'est l'amélioration des
véhicules ensuite
on a un contrôle
technique c'était pas pour rigoler
c'était pour sortir du jeu des véhicules
qui ne répondent pas aux
normes normes donc il y a une
amélioration et de toute façon
l'amélioration elle va se poursuivre
parce que les véhicules
évoluent ensuite il y a aussi une
amélioration qui est catastrophique même
si ça provoque une amélioration c'est
l'effondrement de notre puissance
industrielle
c'est la grande
raison c'est que nos usines ont fermé
c'est que les boîtes ont
fermé ça c'est hyper
écolo la fermeture et le chômage c'est
hyper écolo c'est pour ça que Macron se
tar qu'il a fait Baer les émissions
françaises qu' est sur mais oui c'est
l'effondrement du secteur industriel
c'est la
désindustrialisation et pourtant on nous
a dit qu'on avait
réindustrialiséoui mais en vrai c'est
pas vrai parce que dans système c'est
pas possible avec des ânes et avec des
trucs on peut pas faire des boîtes donc
le
le donc en
vrai il y a il y a parfois des
améliorations écologiques qui sont le
signe de catastrophe donc l'écologie
c'est complexe et on ne peut pas sortir
l'homme faut qu'il soit au centre
question Internet et si l'inattendu
profond c'était justement la crise qui
nous attend
c'est peut-être dimanche question
internet la rol que je lis en même temps
que vous la révolution qu'il décrit
est-elle pertinente par rapport au
contexte géopolitique international
n'a-t-il pas peur que nous perdions
perdons un peu de notre soft power au
profit d'autres pays non moi je pense
que dans le mouvement qu'on est en train
d'engager je pense qu'on va redevenir
une vraie grande puissance culturelle et
éducative c'est beau d'avoir des rêves
ils sont pas payés non non non non il y
a pas de maternité il y a plus on
construit faire lire avec des
clopinettes on fait lire 750000 enfants
donc je sais très bien que si on trouve
des partenaires je peux passer un 5
millions donc donc mais c'est pas du
rêve je sais que si si on prend des
outils et qu'on les développe bah ça va
mieux
hein si si je trouve l'argent à un
moment pour pouvoir encadrer parce que
ça c'est quand même un cout
de il faut donner plus d'argent au
département pour encadrer plus de monde
il faut faire les réunions d'information
VI d'où cet argent
euh il y a beaucoup de gens qui nous
aident beaucoup de campagnes de
d'arrondi en caisse cultura nous a
beaucoup aidé par les campagnes
d'arrondi en
caisse et
puis moi par exemple à côté de ça parce
que je fais pas que ça j'ai aussi ma vie
d'écrivain ma vie de mteur en scène mais
aussi je je mène depuis des années ma
politique du
livre mais je prendre un exemple tout
bête j'étais l'auteur qui enclenché avec
MDO la politique des livres jeunesse
dans les
Happy parce que je voulais qu'on puisse
rejoindre le
peuple éidment tous mes copains m dit
mais comment ça pu MDO on a distribué
140 million
d'exempla qu'on a faitet jeunesse jamais
le ministère de la Culture m'aura donné
le chè et même s'il m'avit donné le
chèque il avait pas la
capacité du marketing d'une boîte pour
arriver vers les milieux populaire alors
que là dans le McDo le gamin vient
chercher sa frite et il repart avec un
bouquin en France il y a combien de
personnes qui payent l'impôt sur le
revenu et à partir de combien on paye
l'impôt sur le revenu je connais pas le
chiffre bon je te la fais en simple tu
as 50 % de la population qui paye
l'impôt sur le revenu et tu as 50 % qui
pay pas l'impôt sur revenu
comment tu veux qu' un pays fonctionne
comme ça où tu vois une sécession des
riches je suis sûr qu'à Paris il y a
énormément de personnes qui payent
l'impôt sur le revenu qui se disent
voilà nous on paye pour les autres on
veut respirer aussi l'air de la campagne
dans notre campagne qui est la ville
est-ce que tu as essayé de les
comprendre ces
gensl je
pense qu'on leura mal parlé
c'estàd je pense que la proportion de
Salo est
faible et que je pense que quand on
parle
réellement de valeur c'est très rare
qu'un être humain préfère ê une
nordure c'est pas fréquent dans
l'histoire quand même il y en a eu
beaucoup oui mais pas tellement dans les
grand nombres au sein de la base des
sociétés
et j'ai toujours dans l'idée
j'ai un rendez-vous demain par exemple
avec quelqu'un du gouvernement
bon avec qui je vais discuter de
ça je suis peut-être taré mais je vais
quand même essayer de lui faire
comprendre certaines
choses tu penses qu' tu penses que ce
rendez-vous il a été fait pour prendre
la température bien sûr bien
sûr mais ils font leur boulot mais je
vais aussi faire le
M ça va ça va être cordial ça va être
brutal parce qu'il est minou moins
une c'est bizarre je te vois pas très
brutal quand il s'agit de défendre les
gens on a le
droit et quand il s'agit de défendre son
pays on a le
droit donc mais on a on a moralement le
droit
bien sûr que à la veille de mouvements
potentiellement très qui peuvent être
très violents à un moment et puis qui va
gagner électoralement dans tout
ça donc qui va gagner électoralement là
actuellement ils sont structurellement
ils ont voté entièrement RN tellement
ils sont cons pourquoi ils sont
cons parce que c'était pas ce qu'il
voulait au
départ c'est ça la connerie non mais à
la limite si on est convaincu que c'est
la bonne solution pour la France faut
faut pas il faut pas juger les gens qui
votent déjà ils vont voter oui
mais il y a une grande irresponsabilité
qu politique
oui or je pense que quand même quand on
[Musique]
le quand on le formule sans détour les
gens sont pas complètement idiots
alors je repense aux écolog de la ville
de Paris que que j'ai essayé de mettre
devant leur contradiction des Menes mais
des Menes c'est vrai qu'ils ont pas
bougé
bon mais en même temps j'ai mis des
graines des gra pour quiipicore non pas
quiipicor mais que ça pousse
doucement parce qu'à un moment donné ils
ont quand même cru dans leur vie à
l'époque où ils étaient à gauche ils ont
cru
ils ont eu un idéal quoi ils sont pas
venus là complètement de manière
cynique
donc tu crois qu'il en existe encore des
politiciens comme ça en France oui
beaucoup de M des m oui ou beaucoup de M
oui mais moi je viens avec
eux je viens avec cette force là un jour
on te racontera quand on a créé un
énorme silence dans le restaurant du
Sénat pour une on le mettra dans notre
livre ça fera marrer tout le monde
question internet ZFE 2 points ghetto de
riche point interrogation mais qui est
enfermé point interrogation le gardien
ou le
détenu c'est ça c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça
que en fait très profondément les gens
du centre du centre des villes
euh il s'enferme dans quelque chose qui
se dévitalise je je vais prendre
l'exemple du cinéma par ex tu parles du
cinéma sous perfusion qui fait jamais de
film et des trucs comme ça c'est notre
soft power en plastique vert moulu bah
qui qui qui est de plus en plus qui
correspond à cette fracture à cette
sécession mais qui rayonne plus qui est
plus vivant moi quand j'étais gamin mon
père écrivait des films je voyais des
passer
Ventura Gabin euh papa écrivait des des
films qui sont devenus des grands
classiques mais ça respirait un mec
comme un mec comme Ventura il sortait
pas du cours
Florent c'était une bête mec il avait
vécu donc il irriigit le cinéma mais ça
venait des milieux populaires mais
vraiment populaire le
le et et pas forcément urbain pas
seulement urbain
mais même même à ma génération je pense
à par exemple
Sophie barsau avec avec qui j'ai fait
Fanfan je me souviens un jour on était
aux États-Unis on regardait le film la
haine de Matthieu Kassovitz de Matthieu
jusqu'ici tout va bien jusqu'ici tout va
bien on regardez ensemble et en sortant
ce film fait une remarque elle me dit
c'est marrant voir la banl en noir et
blanc c'est un truc de bourge je dis
pourquoi tu dis ça moi j'ai grandi en
banl
et l'orreur c'était la couleur c'était
moche dit c'est un truc de bourge mais
Sophie elle venait de la
banlieu vraiment populaire de de la
France populaire donc je je pense qu'on
va rou il a quand même grandi dans le
18e arrondissement de Paris c'est
c'était pas de
Paris tu connais P de clignoncour oui
bon ça a beaucoup poésé mais et puis de
toute façon c'est génial ciné
que j'adore c'est un fou il est pas fou
non non mais je l'adore personnellement
mais son anniversaire c'est au mois
d'août he si tu veux lui faire un petit
cadeau
mais en tout cas je pense que quand là
on va vivre une une révolution
démocratique ça aura des répercussions
dans notre cinéma dans notre littérature
dans notre
culture moi je je pense que de tout ça
peut nître quelque choseextrêmement
fécond question Internet les boomers
doivent-ils faire repentance pour le N
pour le monde qu'il nous laisse je relie
la question les boomers doivent-ils
faire
repentance je dirais même pénitence pour
la pour le monde qu'il nous
laisse il y a pas eu des générations
courageuses génération de grand grand ou
arrière grandsparents il étaient
courageux quand même mais la génération
ça consommé ça pas beaucoup produit
et mais c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave est-ce qu'il faut
leur baisser la
retraite parce que maintenant maintenant
tu as tu as un actif pour de retraiter
pratiquement oui mais tous ces modèles
on voit bien que c'est il fonctionne pas
c'estàd que personne pe il fonctionne
avec de la dette oui voilà donc donc ça
fonctionne pas donc mais là encore quand
on a des idées qu'on a un débat en
France sur les
retraites le vrai problème c'est que
c'est c'est que c'est à chaque fois
tranché en haut c'est des débats que
nous devons avoir dans une
démocratie qu'on doit avoir en en tant
que démocrate qui est-ce qui vote en
France majoritairement non je parle de
démocratie directe et non pas de
démocratie élective
représentative moi je je je je suis très
fasciné par le fonctionnement de la
société suisse j'ai été très ému enfant
euh il y avait quelqu'un qui m'a emmené
dans une votation dans un canton à
l'époque il il votait à main levée je
sais pas si c'est encore le cas
et je me souviens c'est cétait il y
avait des herbages des champs les gens
étaient là et il y avait des compteurs
les gens qui comptaient et j'ai le
souvenir enfant d'avoir vu des gens qui
levait la main mon Dieu est-ce que
c'était
beau parce que tout coup je me souviens
de mon émotion enfant j'ai vu un truc
qui ressemblait à chacun
compte quelle que soit ta position
sociale tu comptes alors je dis pas que
c'est il faut reprendre les formes
archaïque de la démocratie Suisse qui
sont des formes anciennes qui ont lieu
qui ont évolué
qui mais en tout cas je veux vivre dans
un pays où chacun compte et tu crois au
Père Noël non non non non j'organise la
révolte dimanche question internet non
mais c'est pour ça j'ai je peux sembler
anormalement optimiste tu es peut-être
un lanceur d'alerte non
j'organise question internet comment
aider à détruire cette centralisation
parisienne votre pensée des villes qui
est juste Paris n'est-elle pas le
problème c'est le problème donc dans les
débats référendaires vous allez voir que
si les
maires et les citoyens peuvent
porter cette question dans les
référendum vous allez voir qu'il y aura
d'énormes majorité en France
mais quand vous regardez les travaux de
l'Association des maères de France sur
la décentralisation mais c'est très
avancé il y a beaucoup de gens qui qui
sont déjà engagés là-dedans donc en fait
la France nouvelle qui va naître de tout
ça elle est déjà pensée elle est déjà
méditée il y a beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent là-dessus si ça crame tu
seras derrière quel côté de la barricade
oh bah je je suis avec les guux c'est
c'est mais j'ai dimanche je suis sur une
moto devant ou
derrière on m'a piqué mon ma batterie de
de mon SCO donc je peux pas venir avec
la
mienne c'est quoi comme SCO un SCO
électrique parce que pour pas avoir de
PV comment on fait pour piquer ta
batterie sur un scout électrique on
arrache la S et on pique un truc et
quand on veut changer de batterie elle
coûte 2005 donc je vais pas garder le
SCO donc en fait il y a plus de solution
dans leur bordel est-ce que tu tu as
étudié le le fait que les voitures
électriques les machins électriques et
tout électrique c'est des terres rares
c'est de la pollution qui est qui est
chez
chinois j'ai vu des photos d'un d'un
copain qui éit parti au Congo euh
Kinshassa ou brzaville je me souviens
plus des zones mais je me souviens des
photos euh on a l'impression que c'est
la fin du monde ils sont en train de
massacrer leur pays mais massacrer
socialement
écologiquement et tout ça on nous
explique pour nous on va aspirer
pur donc à un moment il faut bien qu'on
remette à plat manière un peu
raisonnée là j'ai beaucoup discuté avec
les les les les organisations de de
automobile en
France pour savoir ce qu'ils avaient
derrière la tête parce que on peut pas
s'en sortir sans eux éement il faut qu'
qu'on fabrique des véhicules non pas à
35000 € la bagnole électrique ou ou
50000 mais parce que ça correspond plus
à rien tant qu'il va falloir qu'on
refasse des voitures populaires
euh et je voulais savoir comment les
Chinois sen sortaient les chinois ils
ont ils partent sur une solution de mix
ils disent pas on va on va arrêter le
moteur thermique puis qu'ils ont une
grosse ruralité ils
ont ils pensent le le le fabriquer
pendant encore 30 ou 40 ans mais des
petits moteurs qui crachent très peu de
saloperie euh et des solutions solutions
mix et tu as discuté avec les
constructeurs européens ouais français
français donc PSA Peugeot Citroën
Renault organisation organisation ils
t'ont dit leurs chiffres de production
ah il sont le modèle actuel il y a plus
de constructeur très vite hein on est on
est au niveau de production de 1962
donc le schéma européen
green ça nous fout tu l'as pas dit avec
l'accent ça fait pas il faut dire green
mais ça nous met les DPE qui vont nous
sortir à peu près 600000 logements du
marché
locatif c'est Dingo sur plan
social il y a une pénurie de
logement et donc ça les DPE on les a en
ligne de mire après les NFE
mais c'est le même problème c'est cette
vision complètement
bureaucratique complètement
verticale et donc j'invite les gens
vraiment à lire mon livre pour qu'ils
comprennent que on doit changer des des
systèmes parce qu'on va pas faire la
révolution pour les DPE la révolution
pour le on va pas il y a un moment on
doit reprendre le contrôle de nos vies
face à des bureaucraties
lunaair est-ce qu'on arrive à la fin de
notre interview est-ce que tu as un
sujet qu'on a pas abordé que tu
souhaiteras
aborder Macron
non mais il m'inquiète pas tellement
parce que c'est les systèmes qui
produisent des gens comme ça le
le il y en aurait eu un autre quoi le
oui la France que j'ai vraiment découver
te en en en montrant en montant le le
mouvement des zèbres à l'époque des
zèbres c'est tellement créatif ça
ressemble tellement pas au journal Le
20EUR c'est tellement profondément
intelligent bien sûr voilà donc le bon
sens mais il est partout mais il est
absolument
partout donc l'idée que ce sera la fin
du monde que on va se scrash de truc de
machin c'est pas vrai
ends j'ai deux questions quand même à
internet c'est pas
vraiutoris à te l une petite question
internet termin tu veux
rajouter pensez-vous que la crise à
venir sera le fruit de l'inattendu ou
bien le résultat prévisible d'un pouvoir
centralisé sour au fractures sociale
territorial et à la perte d'influence
internationale de la
France pensez-vous que la crise à venir
sera le fruit de l'inattendu ou bien le
résultat prévisible d'un pouvoir
centralisé sour au fracture
sociale sour au fractures sociale
territoriale et à la perte d'influence
internationale de la
France il va y avoir beaucoup
d'inattendus là beaucoup ça ressemble
quand même à un truc cousu de fil blanc
là que ça risque de s'embraser ou quand
tu vois qu'il y a pe un peu moins de 20
% de la population française qui va
tomber très prochainement en grande
précarité oui voilà quand tu vois que le
seuil de pauvreté c'est compliqué mais
quand on dit que 25 % sont dans le rouge
a a tout de suite c'est pas possible
donc enfin durablement ça marche pas
question internet un avenir politique
est-il envisageable pour rassembler les
Français et les Françaises de tout bord
politique y compris les abstentionnistes
pour mettre au pouvoir une personne
voulant instaurer une démocratie direct
pour interrogation le citoyen pouvant
alors prendre leur décisions bonne ou
mauvaise mais être maître de leur destin
ce qui semble utopique aujourd'hui on
n'y échappera pas et et et je pense que
quand la masse d'une classe politique
locale le pense ça
arrive est-ce que ça va arriver par une
élection présidentielle est-ce que ça va
arriver par ce qu'on a
lancé ça va
arriver question internet la facture
d'énergie ne -elle pas à persuader les
gens d'investir dans la performance
énergétique plutôt que de mettre des
normes partout des PE
ETFE
mais c'est très important ça c'està-dire
que l'être humain plutôt
intérêt à trouver des solutions mais
intérêt on n pas besoin forcément de
norm mais intérêt dans la mesure où il
peut
c'est là où la norme est
folle c'est de la violence sociale
question internet la grève la grève du
zel sur les a des feux et le blocage des
poids lourds y compris ce qui y compris
ce qui ravitaille les grandes villes
n'est-elle pas une solution
pointinrogation son poids lourd en moins
d'une semaine sans poids lourd en moins
d'une semaine paris tombe or un poids
lourd est pas censé passer une des feux
point d'inrogation
ouais mais mais il y aura pas des
déérrogations pour ravitailler le riches
mais tout le système euh les restos du
cœur leur camion ils sont pas aux
normes comment tu le sais parce qu'on me
l'a dit et une grande partie de leur
bénévoles ont des des véhicules qui sont
pas au norme quoi on ferme lesau du cœur
donc la réponse de de desb buocrate
c'est de dire ah mais on va leur filer
une dérogation mais on peut pas faire
fonctionner une société sous forme de
dérogation ça marche pas c'est la RDA
parce que c'est la RDA ça veut dire
qu'il y a toujours un petit bureaucrate
qui peut vous l'ffiler ou pas ça veut
dire qu'il y a il y a un rapport de pou
RDA pour ceux les plus jeunes qui nous
écoutent c'est répuest l'Allemagne de
l'Est qui é
uneupation que j'ai connu àon les
les c'est un chéma mental mais de
tarer de tarer il faut c'est vachement
important le mot
liberté c'est extrêmement important j'ai
une fille qui s'appelle liberté en
français est-ce que tu as trois livres à
nous conseiller à conseiller à notre
communauté des livres qui ont été
importants pour toi
ou
d'abord les découvreurs de bstin chez
chez
bouquin
euh j'ai appris énormément de choses
c'est un livre que tout le monde devrait
avoir chez soi les découvreurs de de
bourstin B O o R S T N qui était le le
bibliothécaire de la Bibliothèque du
Congrès américain me qui a passé sa
vie absorber des bouquins tu connais le
curateur de cette année de la
bibliothèque
euh un thérapeute hors du commun de
Milton
de Jay
Alley un thérapeute h du commun Milton
Ericson c'est le père de la
communication
indirecte c'est le père de toute l'école
de paloalto ça a l'air d'un psy ça a
l'air d'un psychiatre c'est une pensée
qu'on peut appliquer à la totalité des
activités humaines pens révolutionnaire
et
une
biographie justement la biographie de de
Frédéric
destoffen l'homme qui a importé la
science expérimental arabe en Occident
de Benoît Méchin qui éit un peu une
fripouille mais un
génial g génial biographe euh ça on
trouve ça en en
poche ça ce sont des livres qui ouvrent
le
jeu qui font que on se dit merde [__]
le monde est beaucoup plus vaste que ce
que je croyais dit pas de gros mot sur
notre chaîne parce qu'on va on va se
faire déplatefoner déjà déjà on a un
problème avec l'algo d'ailleurs partagez
cette vidéo un maximum c'est c'est et
soutenez-nous sur tipi parce que nous
aussi on a besoin d'indépendance je te
laisse terminer désolé pour ce petit enc
publicitaire pour la survie de notre
chaîne qui est très importante venez
dimanche est-ce que tu as sinon après
vous chialerez un conseil pour les
jeunes
générations une bouteille à la
mer lisez
lisez lisez tout et n'importe quoi
lisez remplissez-vous de mots Alexandre
Jardin merci
[Musique]